yeah let's just start fresh we're ready
all right man
this is not they're kicking off like
this really figured out what it would
start i did not have the same
sorry yeah man here we are man bro
okay fellas thanks for coming in man
thanks for answering the back call
thanks putting this together mike jason
you're the
jason ellis everybody mike i won't talk
to you so that's that's why mark got me
here i don't even know
who you are how dare you how dare you
man i'm jason ellis though it's nice to
meet you i know i
can change phone numbers one day it'd be
awesome text me and i would [ __ ] show
up [ __ ]
i know dude well but yeah i i feel
you're busy i get it well you're busy
you peddle a lot i say that dude you're
busy are you really that thick
what is with this am i thinking i don't
know that's my big boy that's your thing
yeah i might be calling my bike these
days well i'm always on a bike dude i'm
getting on a road bike
it's helping right i think something
yeah i think so when
it's all i do when lockdown's over he's
my project i'm getting him shredded yeah
i'm making him [ __ ] bruce lee
to be lean in this pandemic you're the
opposite you're the rare right because
everyone's sort of getting fatter
everyone's put on weight do you
do you ride a bike i mean not right now
you gotta
brace on you but i am i have i have big
plans that's why i
invested in having a dead person in my
leg because so just for the
listeners if you're not watching this uh
he has a brace on his leg because mcl
acl pcl um i have no pc i haven't had
that for a long time and i have it at an
mcl and the acl is really stretched out
and some meniscus damage so
i got a new mcl across there to hold the
whole thing in place and then he
tightened up
my meniscus and cleaned up some stuff in
there and seems to think that i'm going
to get a lot more stability than i've
had
since mayhem snapped it off but many
years ago mayhem gave you a kick
right that [ __ ] yeah it was right after
i had the trophy and forest griffin
kicked me in one leg
when he had the sasquatch like he was
dressed as a sasquatch yeah but he
kicked me being funny and i turned
around went ahaha
and it was funny because it was on the
thigh and then mayhem came to the other
side
and kicked me right on the kneecap on
the side of it and it snapped my knee
out
did you know right away no it popped out
like so you did that it did
oh jesus to this to that side and mayhem
was a sweet guy he probably didn't he
didn't do that
he had his hands on his whole crown the
whole crowd saw it everyone was like
no he did not just break that dude's leg
after he won
now is it fair to say your knees are
probably shot because of all your years
of skateboarding yeah yeah they're
already
i've already torn my acl twice in this
one once on that one
like i said no pcl's for the longest
time i feel like [ __ ] forget how good
of a skateboarder you were
i always said when we brought you up on
the show last week i'm like dude you're
talking about
with top three in the world at one point
you know
i ate yesterday on the boardwalk and a
guy came up to me and said no way jason
alex you know the mask on and [ __ ]
and i was like oh wow cool he's like
it's on an honor to me and one time i
met you at a trade show like 15 years
ago and i was like cool man well nice to
meet you
and then the guy the security guy goes
who's that he's like you know who that
is it's jason ellison
legendary skateboarder and i just looked
at my wife and went yeah yeah
hell yeah you know i don't care that's
like those are like every 10 years you
get one of those i'm like
yes random dude legendary legendary
random guy
face mascot yeah i think they forget
because you're shut
such a personality now and on serious on
all over and doing
you know ellis mania and stuff like that
they forget that you're a
high the highest level skateboarder so
do i i mean when you're saying it i'm
like
oh yeah yeah no a little bit that's all
really that's the other bit to finish
the knee off trying to
get back into it because i've been
trying to i made a decision that i
wanted to
ride again love that and then when i got
on the ramp went to tony's and uh
skated for a week tony hawk yeah every
time i knee slid i could tell that it
was
in the comments yeah johnny danza
named tony and then i was at tony's
sorry i've been hanging out with
skateboarders too much again yes yeah so
anyway birdman
so we got so loose that i knew that i
had to do this to skate again
and then how's the uh how serious going
all that
i think it's going good that's the thing
people jason and i are buddies
yeah it's where we talk no because
you're busy i'm busy
it's where we talk and you're just doing
the goddamn thing i'm serious i would
talk to you i have time for you yeah i
have time for you dude
we'll see there's like there's only like
three or four people actively doing it
that i
look at and i go they're they're the
creme de la creme and he's
he's as good as anybody as far as radio
broadcasting he's been doing for a hot
second
yeah he's up and downs with it although
it's and it's not all
like it's a lot harder than
skateboarding even though you don't get
hurt but i feel like just the up and
downs of like you have a lot more
freedom you're you you're your boss i
have people that
you want to be really good jason i've
always had that since the show started
and i'm like well probably what i'm
doing because it seems to be working
they're like no no no
this would be and i'm like that's not
nope that's not true and then working
with people that you're not you're not
butt buddies they put you together and
you start to like
myself and the people i work with
couldn't be more opposite
like what are we into what do we do were
those very complete opposites how those
people were brought on from serious like
you didn't get a picture
it's a total accident it's me being an
accident because they're like well tony
hawk's friend is kind of funny like make
him a dj and they're like wow the show's
getting big
we need to get him some help and there
was more like uh as far as the other
guys knew they were like hey can you
help this guy do his show for a day
and then they stayed and now 15 years
later we've
most of us have been working together
for over 10 years couldn't be more
opposite but
couldn't be more perfect yeah it could
be a good and bad thing
like kevin craft kevin kraft's like a
like a comic book nerd who's into like
cinema and like he's like the comic-con
guy he's
he's that dude and tully's like this
oxford educated
really like erudite intellectual and
it's such an
amazing balance to jason who's like
that's not him you know i had i had
breakfast with tully on
this weekend and my wife said the same
thing she's like that's
like that's the perfect guy to be
sitting next to jason because he's just
so
well informed on so many things because
because if you picked it it might be
[ __ ] you know it might be could it be
another friend
it would be dingo and it'd just be too
australian saying [ __ ] oh my
[ __ ] [ __ ] mate what's the news i
don't [ __ ] know what's news
dingo i don't mind it though he's fine
well
that's that's an angle like i feel like
i feel like you have enough ability
and you believe in yourself you could
probably do it by yourself
really so if i want to because that's
the other thing people forget
i did do it by myself that's how it got
big enough for other people to be there
so i can do that it just makes it easier
to me it's like uh i like relying on
myself howard stern has all these people
and
really at the bottom line probably for
our show he probably does 30 minutes of
him
his content to me like i like the
pandemic i like that there's nobody
around
i like i don't have an executive
producer what are we going to do today
i don't want to know like i used to like
it when it was like what are you going
to do and
i smoke a giant and [ __ ] throw out
[ __ ] and it would work
that's what i love so when it's when
it's like oh we're going to do this and
we're going to discuss and we're going
to do this
tighten up yeah tighten up yeah that's
like the pressure is so much more when
it's
all these things have to play out i like
it better when it's
but that's tully and kevin likes
structure they
and and you've got to work you can't
that's the thing i've learned in the
years of doing the jason l show is
you don't barge on everybody all the
time like i think i came in with a
little video
i just conor mcgregor the [ __ ] out of
this radio show when i first started
i'm like i'm the best i'm the best there
ever is so whatever your opinion is
if if you're not spot on with it i'll
probably nail you to the wall for it be
like what the [ __ ]
i'm not picking apart you don't even
know anything why would i even listen to
you if you're gonna say
such stupid [ __ ] but i i think you need
that arrogance or cockiness to make it
at first
i was the exact same way okay the exact
same i always said it's like you made
adjustments
oh dude dear god have i ever i mean i
haven't struggled now with it with
the team here in in my text means you
have to have a conversation all day
because
through tech might i don't for whatever
and it's a problem you're going to say
the same
it's a problem across the board when i
text it's
brutal yeah and shin's like dude like i
t
send this text he's like dude what the
[ __ ] this isn't you man
he's like call me because the texts are
brutal and it suffers in my personal
life business life
yeah i'm like my i read an email that i
sent to
a big advertiser like dude what the [ __ ]
who are you talking to i'm like you wow
it's but it's through emails because
i've done the same and then when they
called like you're a different person
i'm like it's just the way i tax it's
aggressive
well and it's hard with those two
because they're so hard to get along
with i mean they're really invasive
my girl my family member every my techs
are aggressive
i look at him like all right in the
beginning that that
that um me against the world kind of uh
take no prisoner's attitude
it's really effective but i always say
it's like um it's like
jelly beans compared to like a sweet
potato
the jelly beans give you amazing energy
and they get you fired up
time for 20 minutes and then you realize
like that
it's not sustainable i don't know if
it's a sweet potato you know you're like
learning how to i don't know if it ever
goes away i always have it's just
controlling the monster
like the chip on my shoulders i couldn't
tell you how tall it is
every day this morning that you know i i
woke up you know i have a nice house and
great family i drove my dream car here
but that chip's still like
[ __ ] this it's just he's gonna make
it more difficult for sure
get a couple of losses under your belt
get a couple of people that are a little
bit like on your level to like spank you
back where you belong
i get all that'll help you yeah my
friends my friends are all smarter and
more successful are they
i don't have any friend who's not more
successful than me maybe that's my
that hurts because you're essentially
saying we're not friends
really you're better off than i i've
always known
i'm stupid so you're not hurting my
feelings i have no education i'm on fire
for a dumb guy
like i'm your cr i don't have my dream
car but i have a dream car for a dumb
guy
you're not you're not you're not dumb
and drew and i'm talking you know
you're not you don't you're not educated
you're not educated but your brain
is your brain functioning i did very
well i admit that it's different i just
it's
different bashing myself trust me when i
say dumb guy i know the [ __ ] smartest
guy in the room or i'm just trying to
[ __ ] be flattering to you
[Applause]
go ahead but i feel like you are some
you and i are similar with that athlete
kind of grinding yeah
because you know it works you got good
at sports more than one sport just like
me
yeah from knowing from going nah like
when it's a bad day you're like
yeah yeah like i'm like oh the same with
the knee thing you know not many people
come back from like not many [ __ ]
come back from it you'll be fine do you
know who the [ __ ] i
am like i trained like some dude that's
gonna be in the ufc in six months which
you should all my guys that are
i have three different people that are
gonna be working every day to make this
stronger than it's ever been when i was
a pro skateboarder when you were saying
when i was an elite guy when if i'd have
done this
i'd be just bonging on eating
painkillers
never bothers me no rehab there's no way
i would have gone to rehab i hated rehab
i'd be like
this [ __ ] making me wiggle my knee no
way i'll just [ __ ] watch tv and do
some squats
let it recover yeah like and it worked
when you were younger
but not now but that's that grind you
know but a lot of that comes from
finding a passion you don't get to an
elite level of sports in any sport
unless you're super passionate about it
and like being able to pick and choose
what really means
a lot to you that there's a value in
that and it's hard man it's hard
especially when you're
trying um you like you know lee syat you
know joseph
lovely lee's the best he's not going to
new jersey with joe right i don't think
he is
joe but he is he that little fat guy
that eats crazy amounts of weight is
like 400 pounds now he got bigger he's 5
1 too
which is which is especially impressive
someone's telling me he's like really
heavy now but uh
wait how can you say really heavy now
like what was he before
i'm talking like my 600 pound life tlc
oh [ __ ] yeah someone told me he was like
dude i think he's like 300 400 pounds i
went no dude the video that's the nicest
guy in the world
not i met him before because he hangs
out with tully but i saw him on
diaz show when he ate all those stuff
when his brain broke it was the funniest
weed thing i've ever seen as a guy that
smokes a lot of weed i don't think i've
ever laughed more at someone
that high but yeah this one but he might
but he also looked like
asleep he also looked like he could die
right now like he looked like
that's serious have you ever feel good
though
yeah and if you're telling me he's now
600 pounds
and he still might eat one of those
stuff i'm not sure if he's 600. somebody
told me girl have you seen lee lately
he's
got really heavy what okay 400. bro if
he's that's
honestly and make your like get your
heart real oh my god oh my god dude that
looks like the end of scarface
where i'm like please yeah i'm almost
about to say mama
he's hilarious he smacked me into like
reality
um because i was going through this
thing where it's like i gotta keep
trying new things new things new things
and it's like
everyone knew things in regard to what
professionally all right
and i was like nothing will make me
learn how to like
tighten up my my wit than stand up
because the stakes are so high
because i started doing stand up you
know and uh i was not
great but i was i wasn't bad you know i
think i had potential to be
something but i would go out and do a
set like
three times a week when i was really
balling it up and one night i was doing
when lee was performing i was doing a
set there and um
i showed up and i was like man yeah you
know i'm really trying you know this is
like the
the third second time of this week that
i got and he's like oh man that's
awesome
you know you're doing really well yeah i
just came from an open mic in santa
monica after this i'm going to hit up uh
the place in the valley that i know has
an open mic and he's like yeah i try to
get up like three or four times a night
i was like
oh oh that's that's what it means to do
it and i and then and
it hit me it hit me like a ton of bricks
i was like oh no
stick with what you're really passionate
about and go for it and don't like
don't try to load yourself you can't
really half half-ass stand up yeah yeah
not saying you're half-assed no no i
wasn't like that's but i was
i was i was half-assing it in in
comparison to the stuff that means
something to me where
especially when i was young i had no i
had nothing nothing
you know and people gifted me this
insane opportunity to be
on the radio i didn't [ __ ] sleep and
when i was not on the air i was actively
thinking about more [ __ ] i could do to
get on the air more
like and and like that's not how i was
with stand-up that's not how i am with
personal training or whatever you know
what i'm saying if you're not like it's
hard when you're
older and you've got all these other
things in your life just to just be
you know to do four different sets in
one night yeah
but then get up and you know with your
child
at six in the morning that's totally
true stand up and kids
i'm like what because you guys are all
up late but if it lit my fire if it lit
my fire
i could do it and my wife would
understand you know what i'm saying like
there's times with
with like my animated show um
where yeah i just i just will work for
12 hours not even
needing to it's just like me and having
these meetings over like
the the scheme of yellow that we're
going to be able to put into with the
and i'm sitting here with the animators
and time just flies by it's because like
i can't i can't fathom not investing
myself
to that level um and i still go home to
my kid i still go home to my wife you
know what i'm saying like if you
if you needed me to do something for the
jason ellis show if you had like a giant
bit to pro or like the wrestling thing
yeah like whatever whatever happened
whatever needed to happen was gonna
happen you know like
and that's because it lit that thing
inside of me and i think we all lie to
ourselves with trying to do things that
we're not really that passionate about
if you're not passionate you can get
random man i wish i was more passionate
about comedy than mma
because i don't know about my true
comedy talents but i believe that i
could be
okay handle the job if i was like you
said as passionate as i am about
mixed martial arts at 48 with no
ligaments in my legs like
i'm gonna have another fight what a
pitch scott coker i'm like you should
really shut the [ __ ] up and play
scrabble but have you talked about
subscribing well how dare you
have you talked to scott i've got him
booked for the show because my pitch is
uh because louis j gomez wants to find
me but in an mma fight and i'm like i
heard are you sure dude
i heard i i don't know i met him once he
was very nice to me i don't know him at
all
i saw his fighting against jeremiah
watkins who i thought jeremiah won that
and i'm like you wanna fight jason wait
no he fought did you see him fighted
ellis mania he had an mma fight against
another podcaster a dutch or something
like he had
how did he go did he wait he beat him
like you know he uh he took him down and
albino elbows and stuff he has
submissions and he has a little bit of
boxing i don't have a jiu jitsu
background
no no he's coming he's a nothing back he
has no he's just started training maybe
a couple years ago
he started doing it he got the bug you
know how i do ryan o'neill ryan o'neil
that was that dude yeah yeah
you get guys that have never done it
before and they've got because i think
that's what's fun about it he got bit by
the bug
and he's like and i respect him because
he's kind of i respect people that are
in my level
that get the bug and they step up step
up and they're like i want to scrap
against someone who could fight
because that's what i wanted to do i
wanted to fight you like don't let shane
punch you
but i wanted to see what it was like to
feel power um
he took it anyway let's not get into
that let's not get into that he
this guy wants to fight me and i'm like
i don't think you would do that well and
he's like you're getting knee surgery
you'll be out for six months and i'm
like
yeah i don't know okay but like i'm not
fighting you
right now but when it's better i'll
still have all this stuff but he's
already started training
and he's got videos and he's got a you
know a giant um
fan base of people that love that kind
of stuff
and i'm like if you really want a shot
i've asked well like like if i ask for
uh uriah faber to fight me at ellis
mania like i'm
that was he was doing me a favor yes
you're doing him i believe he did that
because you have a big fit
i mean my fan base is as big as his and
i'm like if we both
show up but his thing is an mma fight
ellis mania's comedy boxing
so if i haven't a sanction it has to be
sanctioned if it's an mma fight
that means i can't have the other fights
where i have blindfolded people with dog
collars on their knees that's not
fun so what do you do well my thing is i
told l
lewis i mean i said let's try and pitch
it and let's get a real fight if you
really want to fight me
i mean scott cocker and see if bellator
will do it i know but you've got to
shoot for the stars
and then like worst case scenario uh
king of the cage wanted me to sign a
three-fight deal and i was like dude
have you talked to lfa no because that
they they also
uh broadcast on ufc fight pass and lfa
they put the most talent out of anyone
besides probably king
cage fury or whatever is in london but
lfa here in los
angeles they're based out of here all
the big names coming out of there and
it's on ufc
that's what uh uh mike uh mike um
ortega came out of there i know our
friend uh
the raider fan white guy who is the most
jasper
mike jasper that's where he found out i
mean legit talent man
look i was i just wanted i'm gonna comp
he picked a fight
i accept let's do this so now i've got a
thing in my head like get your leg
better
get your ground [ __ ] back because now i
feel like i can do jiu jitsu again
because i i couldn't do it anymore
because i had
such little amount of ligament in my
legs i couldn't walk the next day or and
then it got to the point where
saxon's muay thai i couldn't take too
many kicks because
i can't if i if you kick me and i don't
see it coming
i had to at least tense it up even if i
couldn't check it i had to at least
tense when it hit otherwise it would
[ __ ] break off if i'm louis gomez i'm
working on just knee locks
it's that's great you know what i'm
saying i know louis
neelox who's tomorrow paul harris and
he's in new york
go to [ __ ] hanzo's donahue's there
learn knee locks
touch my [ __ ] connect you touch my
foot lewis and see what the [ __ ]
happened
lewis i don't know you very well but
dude he
he is retired and so washed up and
living in a false reality
as i already stated not that smart this
guy's advice don't just because
i know who's gonna win in the ufc he
might be right about that but you are
you know what you need to do is [ __ ]
kill yourself and then be
reborn as someone who can fight because
i am born to beat you
jesus that's what it is you can flick
this thing and i think he's going to
do that and win the fight yeah i'm a
betting man i'd put all my money on you
yes
yeah i know you i don't know him i've
already that's the other thing i did a
fight where i lost
badly as badly as i ever tried king of
the cage dude i got stung like four
times and was like whoa
i didn't even see him anymore and i had
my hands out i'm like wow
this is the end fell on the ground now
he's mounting me and i'm like what now i
see him again i'm like
okay and i moved and rolled and wiggled
and [ __ ] got back up and had no like
at the end of the first round i was face
out here
couldn't breathe i saw it in all coaches
eyes
it's over and uh and i was like let's go
like let's get and then i [ __ ] like
it i felt like a tractor
slower but just kept going because if he
got stung i just did
i started wrestling i started throwing
leg kicks and did you beat him yeah i
submitted him
with one second in the third round by
keylock goddamn brother
that's a big deal but it was like a you
know dude you've had real fights like
where where
usually it's like you i've had people
box me and they're better i fought
mma guys and i'm gonna find a way you're
gonna find a way this was a really
fighters find a way that's why i didn't
really need to do another one because i
i wasn't i don't need a pat on the back
i wanted to prove to myself
you checked that box you went there yeah
yeah i was like how much tougher do you
need to be
jason that's enough that's totally
enough i agree
that fight was nuts it was like two
hours away
you know like a lot of people didn't
recognize that it was so far away it was
deep in the like inland empire
and my wife's like oh i'll definitely go
with you you know we get a babysitter
and everything we're all excited
we drive way the [ __ ] out rob cordray
came in a three-piece suit
oh wow so nobody knew what i was
bringing them to
me we're standing next to rob cordray my
wife and i were standing getting ready
we're excited and jason comes out fight
starts
and he's fighting this gnarly like cholo
gabe rivas right yeah greater tattoo
oh hell yeah short little cholo it's
like stalky
and he comes out and cracks jason in
like the first
20 seconds of the fight and where rob
korg looks over me and goes
what are we doing like what is what
jason was jason was on queer street
and i was like oh no and she trapped me
right away [ __ ] warrior came back and
and
submitted him i raced cars the same day
so i've i may i [ __ ] up by trying to
do too many
she got yeah that's right you i thought
it'd be cool and you got a great ref too
yeah he was awesome yeah you know what
because he he actually stopped the fight
that dude didn't tap
he was just screaming and his arm was
popping and he called it
yeah that was tough as [ __ ] but i could
tell my coach was like hey
it's a fight and i'm like why is he
telling me that right now because you
can tell i wasn't
i was sort of like hey what do you guys
do and it was like okay touch gloves and
i'm like yeah touch gloves
jab move back like well just not not in
it not till
not till he [ __ ] smashed me where i
was like oh man here we are
this is it huh and then and then the
whole this is the thing that's so great
about it like the
the burning in your chest where you're
like and i'm like
and i'm like what the hell was that
punch like are you
wait rubber arms burning and i'm like
can he tell in my face
that i'm done and this whole thing
that's happening between us it's so
awesome it's a weird dance
i just i know as long as i don't fight
anybody like you i got a couple more in
me so
[ __ ] that's my name no in shape you were
dude
speed of sport that's what's his name
yeah nick carson i'm getting back with
him too
you're full and when is alex mania oh
to be determined you've got to be joking
me yeah you got supposed to be
ellis mania 20 20 20.
but now i believe it'll be alex mania 20
in
21 because march who knows dude
that was it that was the one where i was
like uh oh this is bad news
watch let me see oh that right hook guy
dude and that's a
shot on the ball yeah right i didn't i
didn't see it i really didn't see it
that's the worst ones
yeah and then there were there were
several more but right here i just hear
a humming sound
yeah okay it's like you can't hear
anything but i knew
my mindset was when i couldn't see was
like i'm gonna [ __ ] kill this dude
interesting was it wasn't like let's
stop now like i was like no
where no any anything but lose yeah
anything like it all cost jason
find something to hold on to him like i
just remember going no
i will not i will not yeah and then like
oh i see oh there's a chair i'm back oh
and then
it comes back you're being like half
grown like oh there we are i know this
yeah yeah yeah yeah like okay there we
go the boy with the very end
jasper was making fun of me because of
my first fight
there was video of uh i was in i was
like uh in his
in uh his garden and he's god and i he
and and jason's going
posture posher and i'm not posturing so
he goes
posture mate bust your mate
i guess i
watching that video and this is [ __ ]
seven years later and in the third round
with like
a minute left and i mean he's got it i'm
trying to get up there for that key lock
again and i hear
bashar mate posture me and i'm so tired
i still had that like i was like
he did not you did i like looked at him
through the cage like you're [ __ ]
joking right now you're busting my balls
with my
i didn't deform my head permanently like
this part got bigger
and this part like came over here a bit
i'm like a little bit more wobbly
so how are you and uh lewis gonna be
able to do
uh it has to be sanctioned so i just say
what you said go to those
pitch it to the real people and have a
real fight at the end that way i don't
have to organize an event i'm sure ellen
would be yeah that'd be a nightmare i'm
sure lfa that would be down it's
terrible
you got a guy at lfa yes
well let's pretend we're friends still
while we're on the
that's why you're here man i shouldn't
want to bother you no i'm not
pumped for that because that's yeah is a
big deal
oh i'm aware of it i just figured i'd
you know
small but i'm like but i know it's got
coco i'll trap him on the radio
and then i'm like he'll say no because
the king of the cage loved me they were
like
no issue with king and cage again king
cage had some great fighters
bellator is a little different because
now bel when you're dealing with
bellator you're dealing with cbs show
time
because now they're with them you're
dealing with paramount ufc and espn
and you're dealing with much higher big
wakes like wait what you want to do what
right hey kids one thing that's
important is what you sleep on
and i'm here to tell you about helix
sleep mattresses helix sleep has a quiz
that takes just two minutes to complete
matches your body type and sleep
preference with the perfect mattress
just fo yo big ass with your side
sleeper hot sleeper
firm bed soft bed whatever you want
helix has
the bed for you helix sleep was awarded
the number one best overall mattress
in 2019 and 2020 by gq and wired
magazine
what's up in my house people always
trying to stay with me
all the goddamn time like why i'm not
that friendly the food's pretty good my
girl can cook
maybe it's my kids nope it's my
mattresses
every guest room i have has the helix
mattress
and people are trying to take over my
crib just go to helixsleep.com
fighter take their two-minute sleep quiz
and they'll match you with a customized
mattress
that will give you the best sleep of
your life they have a 10-year warranty
and you get to try it out for 100 nights
risk-free
they even pick it up for you if you
don't love it but you will so no worries
there
helix is offering you guys up to 200 off
all mattresses and free pillows for you
guys at helixsleep.com
fighter that's helix sleep.com fighter
for up to 200
off helixsleep.com fighter oh
snaps ufc 252 stipe dc is this weekend
you got nba you got mlb uh nhl
playoffs you got it all and you want to
make money well guess
what draftkings has brought their
expertise to legal sports betting it's
legitimate sportsbook
based right here in the us of a so you
can rest assured that your funds are
totally secure
draftkings america's top rated
sportsbook app is safe secure reliable
you can deposit withdraw your money
whenever you want new users
listen to this you can bet one dollar
you win 252 dollars
place a bet for one dollar on either the
main event for ufc 252
either fighter for the main event and
you can uh have the opportunity to win
250
252 dollars you can't beat those odds
new users get a sign up bonus at a
thousand dollars up to 1 000
head to the app right now check out all
they have to offer including player
props
live betting so much more my lock of the
week that i said on below the belt
is jds over rosenstroke he's a dog
make money bet on the heavyweights it's
the risk but it's fun
jds as a dog if sportsbooks is not
available in your state don't forget
about draftkings fantasy app
they're offering a shot over 1 million
dollars in total prizes every day this
week
download the top rated draftking
sportsbook app now use the code
fighter when you sign up for a limited
time all new users can get a signup
bonus
up to a thousand dollars that's right
draftking sportsbook has a signup bonus
up to a thousand bucks
just enter the code fighter when you
sign up only at draftkings sportsbook
must be 21 or older
new jersey indianapolis or pennsylvania
only bonus comprise the first deposit
bonus first bet match up to 500
each deposit bonus requires 25 times
playthrough restriction supply
cdraftkings.com
sportsbook for details gambling problem
cool
call 1-800 gambler or in indiana 1-809
with it
again that's draftking sportsbook apps
promo code fighter they don't seem like
they're that hard on gimmick fights
either
i noticed i did uh actually evan smith
podcast and she said
you did actually evan smith podcast yeah
the sex and violence thing
just like the other day she hit me up
and i'm like yeah cool i never she's
great
yeah but she she said one thing when i
mentioned that was
i don't know how like some of the real
fighters would feel but you know i mean
i'm stoked for you and i was like
wait you're saying you're saying if i
get on the card i'm taking somebody's
spot because to me
in from skateboarding if you
skateboarded and you didn't make any
money but you still came to the ramp
with me for as long as i did
you were better to me you were more i
had more respect for you than me
because you people gave me money and
[ __ ] free
everything yeah to keep skateboarding so
it's easy pretty easy to keep going yeah
this guy's breaking ankles and getting
switched off and just showing up and
going oh mate i bought my skateboard at
the part at the shop
and i'm still doing the same [ __ ] to me
like i'm at the gym
all the time people crack me i get hurt
i'm
i train i'll do sprints i hate sprints i
was doing sprints with the saxon dudes
and vomiting because they're all like
140 pounds [ __ ] but i'll do it because i
love
i love the game i'm not doing it for
anybody but me
so if i'm that passionate about mixed
martial arts and she was saying that you
were gonna take someone's spot on
because
she just it's she sounded like it was
like a i might bum out some real
fighters by being on a
did you respond such a big did you
respond back to that that i said
i felt like i was bringing more people
to the event
and that if you're really that mad at it
like after i beat louis
if you want to beat me up on tv to get
like more people i'll show up
like i'll take a fight against the dude
sure if that's
what you need from me but i just figured
am i really hurting mixed martial arts
no i don't think so
punching louis j gomez in the face on
television no
and i you it definitely will give you
more fan bases right it would bring more
people to
a lot more people you know i mean it's
similar not similar that's not fair but
like what jake paul is doing
with which i love i mean i don't know
about i don't like jake paul as a person
i haven't met him but he seems
kind of mean and like you said where you
had like a bit of an ego for a while and
you weren't like
adapting to just being civil with the
rest of the world i feel like he's still
on that
he's very young though dude so i give
him a pass but logan
seems like you know logan at all yes i
met him he seems really nice right great
dude but he's also
he's older he's been through some [ __ ]
took a loss took a lot so he has more
experience
but he's a good dude but even like he's
a great guy
so his brother is younger but when
people want to [ __ ] on that stuff i'm
like
don't [ __ ] on it if people are going to
pay for it and there's an avenue let
them have their fun dude
why do you care he's live main main
event on the zone
and there's like a bunch of like real
guys that none of you have ever heard
about dude
on the undercover billy joe saunders was
the co-main event and now you're getting
you should fight canelo
next he's a monster yes i yes i thought
it was like she's talking to me like
yeah yes he's nuts but i'm saying he's
brilliant he was saying you're going to
fight billy joe sanders next
that's good i think it's a good idea
it's a good fight yeah i throw my
steroids up as soon as i get home
yeah but but it's like if those guys are
bringing this younger audience and
there's a
and people are p now if no one's paying
attention i don't know what the [ __ ] you
guys doing
but if it's bringing new eyeballs and
springing money and everybody's getting
paid
i don't care now i don't like the roy
jones mike tyson i'm not into it the
jake paul i'm not really into it
but if you guys want to pay for it and
there's that i'm not gonna hate on it
i'm not gonna [ __ ] on it
do your i don't give a [ __ ] can i ask
why you don't like the
tyson fight are you worried about them
more
a little bit both i'm just not into it
i'm i'm into
dc and steep a3 i'm into real [ __ ] yeah
i'm not saying it's not real but
you know they have bigger gloves on
they're into you know
they're older it's not the same anymore
well my thing would you want to see
you know uh you know magic johnson and
larry bird play if they're you know
their balls are down to their ankles
i said yes that last week yesterday i
was like yes but i'm not i would really
want to say that
i'm not hating on them only they're
bulls really i don't care
as long as their balls come out larry's
larry's are sagging
larry's are happy i'm not i'm not
probably better looking than his face
but there's just there's so much good
fighting going on i'm just like all
right if you want to do that do that but
i'm okay over here i get that
i'm more about them like what do they
want and you know i feel like you're
different because you've
found all these other things to because
i feel like you had a pain from the
football thing not being like
the greatest football player at all time
and then you got that fire that made you
get in mma and was like i'll [ __ ]
fight
everybody i don't give a [ __ ] how many
years i've got behind me correct and
excel to the point where you're in the
[ __ ] ufc
yeah because you had a fire like my fire
for radio from the skateboard thing
could have done better in skateboarding
there's a few things that i felt that i
left
that i should have done and that fire
built in the radio so i have that
you used you applied it to all these
other things so you don't have that
uh because you know the guys at the gym
dude that are like oh
i could probably i could probably take
that guy i mean if i would get a camp
like
like a king jardin could potentially
fight anybody at any given moment
but he doesn't he shouldn't he knows
that yeah
but it's in there like you hear old guys
war guys
real fighter guys that are like muhammad
ali before it but he was before he like
could barely talk
he used to announce [ __ ] after he
retired and almost
every time he announced he'd be like
dude right now i do it right we'll get
back here i gotta camp
we'll go back and he's trying to
organize fights for like the last
20 years of his talking life he was
threatening other heavyweight boxers in
the ring
to challenge him because he would never
stop and see i'm not that i'm not that
guy but are you are you smarter you've
got joe rogan's
brain hitting advice like i remember joe
when i had my first photos like dude
one knee i'm like what you shoot
one knee it's over my ex-wife's standing
next to me i'm like dude
on the knee yeah yeah yeah he has to be
on the brain damage here
[Laughter]
but like because he's smart he's a
thinking man he's
seen a lot of stuff right i don't have
i feel like i don't have but dude but do
you watch skateboarding girl i could
[ __ ] do that dude
uh i watched i totally have watched it
lately and go
there's a couple of things that i can
still do if i get my [ __ ] back where
their high level sh they're high level
stuff can i match the top 10 dudes no
[ __ ] way it is so beyond over even if
i put like
retired from radio and was there every
day there's new things that they do that
i could never do
but the big big 540s and [ __ ] those are
i don't know what it is in mma to
compare it but if you can do like a
eight foot five forty you're kind of
forever
in the top ten because there's only
about and you can do that
i've i used to be able to do every grab
eight tail grab ones
see like i don't i think i think that's
different is like i'll watch
like steep and dc fighting it doesn't i
guess just so i'm so far over here now
with other things
it doesn't even come into my brain like
ah you do pretty well against them or i
used to be a train partner with stipe
i've trained with dc it doesn't even
enter my brain you're free
yeah to me that's free that's to me to
that's why i'm back in skateboarding
till i hurt my knee because i couldn't
go back
because i couldn't deal with i used to
go to venice every now and then and
there'd be a guy i think i've told mike
where there's a guy i don't know who he
is
he doesn't know who i i am and he's
destroying me
yeah and i haven't skated for a while
but i'm like the [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
and i'm like
jason are you really having a bad time
now
because this random kid is shredding you
up at the bowl
yeah like dude get over it this is this
is ten years after i retired yeah so
it's taken a long
time to like really get a grip on my ego
and understand what it's good for and
what it's bad for
and and and like allocating when it's
when it's time to bring that in and
we're trying to shut it off it's a good
thing i think it's a good thing if you
can
figure out how to control that beast
it's a good thing like do you
i don't know how it works with serious i
have no [ __ ] clue about sis do you
take that up like your ego into like
numbers gaming series because they don't
tell you guys
uh he's way different than he used to be
no i don't i don't care anymore when it
comes to that
i just care about did you used to yeah
yeah big time me too now i can't tell
you the last time i've looked at
how many downloads we have or the i just
put out the content if you guys dig it
cool
as long as if over here like yeah we dig
it man i just keep going
well there's what's healthy for you like
you thought about it at the start
because you needed to
get momentum to go like attack attack
if you want to be good at [ __ ] you don't
do it kicking back no you go 110
what are you thinking about [ __ ] that
thing that's gonna make me rule
i can barely hear what anyone else is
saying because i'm just like get the
radio get to get to say the best thing
what's what am i gonna do next what's
what do you want but tomorrow what kind
of story are you gonna come up with like
it won't [ __ ] turn off
i was foaming at that right and then
when you get there you can't
show up every day smashing the roof when
you're already sitting on top of the
hill like it's
like now it's not it's not sustainable
sort of help
people now i wanna people that listen to
the show and like my show yeah what can
i do
to help you is there something i could
do do you
mean to say do you want to say some
other stuff or do like would i hang out
or maybe like talk to your
like like uh you know the gay community
reach out i try to reach out to people
that are
hiding and they want to come out like
that's my
thing more now like what do you mean to
help people what do you mean your thing
what like that like that's now the show
like you're
that you're doing the show so you hope
those people that are
in hiding come out no i'm saying that's
my main focus on like what do i really
i care about the show being good but i
know the show's good i need to show up
ready to go every day and we'll be fine
yeah so that bit's taken care of
it's more about if people reach out to
me and go hey man i know you were
talking about this i haven't felt good
about it or
what would i do with depression or i'm
doing doing drugs or
i'm thinking about going to a gym or i
don't know those are that's my
that makes sense that's time for me to
do my job that's the job where i'm like
hey man
because sometimes i'm like oh god the
last there's so many people asking me
questions some of them are like hey
we're gonna go i'm like oh
dude i can't tell you what kind of yeah
i have to tell everybody in my car no
but if it's real help where i can people
have said they're going to kill
themselves
and then they haven't that's heavy so
that's all i'm here for
and my kids and my wife that's those
people i'm just like
they care enough for me to say something
please jason say something that can help
them like get your brain together yeah
yeah that shift though
for you as someone like i feel like i
have a pretty good
um perspective on you as a
as a broadcaster because i do your show
once a week so i'm there i see it from
you you do it every once every friday
you're back talk fridays brandon
batcock friday ironic that i get to jump
up son because we have big dick monday
here
yeah we should hang out i should do a
crossover show on wednesday
like the meeting of the monday yeah he
didn't get that one it's probably good
um but like for me i and and i also i
know you
as a person very well and i think that
the show
has in the last two years or so gotten
increasingly better
it was just because of jason's personal
shift
he grows he is such a different guy
because that that desire to light the
world on fire has gone away and jason's
just more invested in being
a better jason and um
he's so much easier to work with and his
co
is his actual you know i was so bad
his actual like co-host and stuff
because i only have to deal with once a
week
i only have to deal with once a week and
jason always has cut me a different
sense of like reverence and stuff
compared to his
like daily co-host but like it was just
tough because he's such a type a guy
he's so ambitious he's so hardcore
i feel like he totally i feel like
you've done some
stuff it's that's what like famous
people freak out people attack i'm like
if you had like a million dollars
and all of a sudden everybody loves
everything you do have you had that
happen to you
because until you have i don't want to
say shut the [ __ ] up but you don't know
kind of shut the [ __ ] up
you should shut the little shut [ __ ]
up because you don't know maybe you've
been
next to somebody that had it you could
kind of know
but even even then she should still shut
the [ __ ]
because it's up man it is like i'm
trying to navigate that world man
i even feel like what you're saying
right now people are going to like oh
they're bitching about being successful
well not
don't get them very happy to be here
just saying you don't [ __ ] know no
you don't
it's like look at this [ __ ] you've
never been hot [ __ ]
you have your right dude but it's also
with like the turmoil i've dealt with in
2020 with friends and their issues
be like dude you need to do this you
should do this like oh yeah have you
ever have you been in this situation
have you ever been the situation that's
not the way it works man
i think it makes it even harder i feel
like being up and
and things are always usually win i mean
usually i'm on the right track i've done
the bad things in my life
i kind of know where i excel and i
usually pick the right thing these days
usually i win if we're doing stuff man
you're doing pretty good no
no [ __ ] seems to happen to me for a lot
i'm [ __ ] work hard for that's why
it's absolutely when bad things happen
and you've been just like playing it
along and it's like
you're like whoa i was like on the
cruise ship yeah man
with my you're getting a tan what the
[ __ ] is happening there it makes it come
from
i feel for you man i'm sorry it's also
it's also like
i've i've said it so many times and
people will dm me with questions
because they don't understand but like
i've always said
my life was so much easier when i was
using drugs and drinking every day
my life's so much better now it's a
million times better
my life was so much where are we going
yeah my life was so much easier
i woke up i had one thing on my mind i
was like where am i going to get
drugs where am i going to how how am i
going to start drinking
and then i achieved that and everything
was fine yeah and i didn't worry about
mortgage
i didn't worry about being respected by
my child i didn't worry about my wife
and her your feelings i didn't worry
about my standing professionally
yeah now i everything is so so high i'm
so
kind of high strung when it comes to
like remaining
above the standards that i set for
myself when you set no standards
it's really easy really but but it's
also it's not very fulfilling you know
and it doesn't make you very happy you
know and i think that that's
on a larger scale that's kind of the way
things are in any professional
field you when when you're just kind of
scratching the surface you don't really
hold yourself to that kind of standard
but then when you get to a point where
you have success
it's it's it's it can be miserable to
then
try to not only maintain it
professionally but also maintain your
sanity
within that world you know it's it's and
again it's not bitching about being
successful i'm simply saying
especially in entertainment and sports
because there's
no [ __ ] stability and having no
stability in your life as a grown man
with a family
crazy is really [ __ ] hard to wrap
your head around with
you know it's it's then you toss in
social media and there's a million
opinions and there's this and there's
that
so i'm like i'm out yeah well if you
care yeah
people on there exactly and every now
and then you go down a wormhole of
you're having a conversation where you
care and this person was just
trying to ruin your day yep and now
you've been booby trapped into hey man
but you see the thing
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you suck dicks and i'm
like ah
[ __ ] man i was trying to help like
[Laughter]
yeah but but do you find though like i'm
sure you both have experience with it
for every one of the yeah but you suck
dick guy there's also the
the dude that you respond you know even
if it's a troll and you respond you say
something the guy goes
oh dude i didn't think you were gonna
actually respond i'm sorry i
didn't mean that i that happened so much
where i was like well i'm sorry you feel
that way i i guess
i'll try to do this there's a lot of
people that go and yep you still suck
dicks
yeah yeah just so you know like oh thank
you
i'm like oh man really just like this
give me a break like you [ __ ] suck
mad dicks
did i say bad dicks yeah everybody gets
it i wouldn't classify you with someone
who smokes or
sucks
[ __ ] watch it all right like i'll
make some dick sucking jokes but now you
tell
but you're not a mad dick sucker yeah a
different game
what about every time i suck dick i suck
at like a mad man does that make mad
dicks
that makes you good little tweak there
you go look if i'm gonna do stuff i
already said i do it
when it comes all in when i committed
you know what to the point where if you
suck my dick poorly
i'm kind of baffled
i felt like i feel like a lot of young
and by the way meaning when i was also
young but uh hot super hot chicks
sucked it poorly because they're like
why would i have to like you know what
i'm saying that's not why you do it you
do because you want to otherwise don't
yeah i feel like there's
girls that are so [ __ ] hot they don't
they they're like i don't want to be
doing this yeah you can get it or
whatever
you got it all wrong yeah you know what
about if you liked it
yeah i'm more into getting big tits
that's what i'm into you want
yeah i've always had baby tits yeah you
got to get them here i know you got
no sick tits you mean like benching yeah
yeah not a boob job oh i was like i
can't see how you would think that
though that's fair
i just talked about sucking dicks i know
i was like really dude yeah be tough to
fight with you yeah
i was like you know what come on the
titties would be pretty hard
and i don't have any so yeah that's like
maybe if i'm grinding on hey
these maybe more people
if you want to do that dude i'll support
you man my show would be huge if i had
two
maybe bigger maybe just giant [ __ ]
just wearing like sweet like lingerie
and [ __ ] while i do the show
my next guest will be covered in it and
he's like well
excuse me yeah eyes up like beautiful
beautiful like kate upton titties
he would be on my tits i would we could
never have a friend remember again
i'd be like dude yeah here on my eyes up
buddy
i couldn't stop he would never stop i
feel like he would come on him if i
slept [ __ ] yeah
i'd come on your chest now wait what
whoa i mean if you wanted me to
why do you keep doing that i'm just
saying hey but you're you're into big
titties though that's your thing right
now
it's like a phase no no i mean i got in
trouble with my wife the other day
because i was like this chick is so hard
she was like she's gross
i'm like come on you don't get it she's
like this big giant saggy tears i'm like
yeah
big giant dude big old ass and guts
everywhere
it's like a monster you gotta handle it
[ __ ] take care of it keep it all in
there while you're doing stuff
she's like you are tweaked yeah like
just let me have my thing
that's your thing because it's like big
sloppy ones
or like big big ladies
you know and because they're bigger they
talk to me like i'm a kid
they call me sugar and [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
where do you find these big [ __ ] at
on the streets you know i get around oh
on the streets you know hometown buffet
usually tenders and stuff like that you
see a big one they're probably
slowed down to me it's usually i'll they
know and i know
like if i'm gonna there's nothing more
but when i was out about in places
if there was a bigger girl there like
i'm you know hanging out the table
and then i'm like all right it's it it's
on she's a look and she's
she's looking at me she's like oh this
guy likes people you're like a chicken
tender look at my you're damn right you
see like a lion
and you're like a zebra cause that's
what you're seeing right now a pants on
that [ __ ]
handle but has how long has the big girl
thing been going on
i wonder what's from 25 years i mean
i've always had a
crazy spectrum of people like what kind
of girl you're into and i'm like i'll
allow
i'm into girls that are heavily tattooed
i'm into a lot of black girls
the rest is completely you can't pick
same with guys it doesn't
count it's just one thing i'm gonna get
and you
suit that thing so if it's like a big
girl sex thing then we're gonna have big
girls sex and do
because it's a different kind of sex
there's all different moves differently
there's
there's weight in it there's moving
stuff it can't be light in the ass
yeah it's like sleeping with china you
know it's a different you're going to
have wrestling sex
we're going to have big shoulder
wrestling sex he meant the country
yeah billion people jesus [ __ ] china
yeah he [ __ ] it
i don't feel like my tits are big enough
to be honest you like muscular chicks
yeah yeah i want to sleep with ufc
fighters girls
ricky martin of ufc he hate his stumpy
arms and his bold patch on the back of
his hair
[ __ ] that picked out his two flaws he's
so beautiful though yeah he's a good
looking
he's really handsome so she loves him
she posts about him all the time about
how she wants to suck him off and [ __ ]
i'm like
you're just showing everybody you want
to [ __ ] stumpy i hope izzy kicks him in
the face
so that i can stand in the room
i think he i mean he is a better striker
and if they're getting a job
it's better than than than polycaster
[ __ ] yeah way better but you know the
little gloves supercharger should happen
if he punches you you're going out
he's a young [ __ ] too paul acosta he's
a he's a tough guy i think it's if he is
he's easiest match up in a while though
i think he starches him
so do i yeah because i keep i've got
better starches he's just a
thou he has a thousand more moves and
he's not scared he's not going to like
get weird if he's fought big strong
knockout artist before you know
he's he is a a really slick refined
striker too
like i don't think people understand
like stopbender is
can go [ __ ] ninja mode and that's not
that's better there's not that many
fundamentally yeah he's the best there
everything everybody
everything is the best we have to offer
the best we have the best product we
have
he might be the best in the ufc uh now
that i think i can only think of
people that are the best on his level in
mma
in striking i can only think of like a
couple like gaston bolanos
in bellator that guy's [ __ ] st and
and joe schilling obviously he comes to
mma though
i can't think of those guys can't hold a
candle to stubborn yeah he's
he's pretty immediately whitaker dude
that's insane
it is insane and he didn't get taken he
like
did not get out wrestled by nuts dude
anybody
uh with uh the sirius family howard
stern is on his last
contract right you sure yeah i mean i
don't think those dudes leave i think
they're just larry king it
they just do like he'll do like three
days a week or two days a week they're
just gonna cut down everyone's all will
never
leave i'm like where's he gonna go
they'll never shift him to me it's over
and i'm too roaring what do you what do
you mean you mean
the whole i just talked way too much
about
you know like cern did this new thing
where he's got celebrities and he's a
little less raw and that's sort of what
mainstream wants from people and i'm
i've gone the opposite
you know i mean blown grinder it's not
yeah it's not like mainstream like oh
man let's get a bunch of sponsors and
they are on that tip they want
corporate sponsors i get it i don't sell
yeah
they're like wait what did he just say
yeah theragon doesn't want to know about
my saturday night [ __ ] big girls yeah
yeah yeah
because people love hearing about
[ __ ] people no but they're yeah i
think howard is like how you were
describing muhammad ali
in his retirement he still was at fights
going no no i'll get in your camp and
then
like i think when it comes to
broadcasting and doing a radio show
the guy there's that fire has not gone
out
his interviews are good it's a different
show though for sure it's also listening
it's wildly different but it's i don't
think he's that i mean i think he lives
and breathes
doing quality radio and he could never
be stuck
he would die pulled away from him yeah i
agree i don't know what he would do
like regis like he might just leave for
like the last five years of his life and
then dies
that match he's pretty healthy yeah i
think that dude just like eats
little bits of salmon like he sounds
like he really takes care of himself
he's doing better his parents are still
alive
yeah i know the dude's [ __ ] 70 and
his parents are alive what else she
going to do dude
and they're lucid like his dad can't
hear very well but he's still
sharp right here he will be able to call
the show he's so bad i can't go
jason yeah all right wait that's how
that works yeah if you
[Laughter]
hey y'all it's been reported that
americans are overpaying on car
insurance by over 20
billion dollars 21 billion dollars
forget 20 21 billion dollars
by searching for a better deal can take
hours typically results in a barrage of
underwater spam calls all that hoopla
don't worry about it until now there's
the
the zebra.com is the nation's leading
car insurance
comparison site because it's the only
place you can compare quotes
side by side from over 100 providers
choose the best for you in 90 seconds or
less plus
they will never sell your information to
spammers none of that so you won't get
those unwanted calls or emails
you just answer a few simple questions
it's quick it's easy
you find the best rates and coverage in
your state um
techcrunch calls the zebra kayak for
auto insurance the best part is it's
completely free
you can save up to 670 a year by using z
the zebra.com all right how much can you
save on car and home
and home insurance go to today
and start saving at the zebra.com
fighter that's the zebra.com fighter
it's spelled
t-h-e-z-e-b-r-a dot-com slash fighter if
you can't spell the zebra you probably
shouldn't have a home or car
but the zebra.com fighter so
realistically when do you think you can
start like training training
well i uh i went in the water yesterday
nice with the knee brace on
in the ocean yeah nice and moved around
in it so i can move my leg
so i got another tomorrow i get physio
and she gives me the hall pass on what i
can do next
but i can go in the water now so i think
i'm gonna ask if i
nick curson can start coming around
awesome i don't know how much further
i'm going to ask if i can hit pads
because now i can sit down a little bit
i don't want it to rip or anything so
i'm doing what everybody tells me
but i think because um
i'm upping my steroid intake very good
[ __ ] has changed man the hgh is no joke
i could say that right
yeah i got legal hgh it's not i got it
from my doctor but
he said double up and ever since i've
doubled up
i can just tell i know my physio comes
tomorrow she's gonna go holy [ __ ]
yeah we could probably do this this and
this but i don't
so i don't know if i can move around i
don't i know i can't jump up and down or
squat
but i don't know what the rules of is it
having is it realistic to think like you
could be training hard in like six weeks
no no that's not i i cause i think it's
more
uh in six weeks from now can i squat no
but can you run but yeah could you be
could you do an exercise bike full speed
go to like muay thai and like actually
train and hit a bag and
hit pads i think hitpad is for sure i
don't know about getting hit
so if that's where you're at in six
weeks like
spring of 2021 we're thinking louis jay
gomez yeah because i want at least
i want to fight camp after it's 100 yeah
then i want three months of fight camp
or two months sorry [ __ ] yeah i'll be
fine
he i saw he posted a video where he's
240 pounds he's a bigger guy than you
and he has to
he's because i think he's trying to get
i don't even know what weight class he's
trying to i think he's trying to fight
me at 205
yeah but his whole thing is like can i
get
40 pounds is a lot out of shape
yeah if your fight weight is 205 and
you're walking it
240 and you don't look like paul acosta
right no and um and like the
the george lockharts and mike dolce's of
the world like the guys who are the best
at it
they'll tell you like uh joel romero
paulo costa
it's much easier for them to cut weight
than it is for dc
or you know someone who's carrying a
little more talking about uh
yeah how tall is he he's like the same
hot as me oh
is he out of shape he's fat yeah oh [ __ ]
so he said he posted a video
what do you weigh probably like 2 15.
so you guys are gonna fight at two or
five whatever he wants i said one i said
195 but if whatever he wants i don't
care
catch weight i don't really care about
that part but he should be more
concerned about just being in shape than
what he weighs because that's all i care
about
if he wants to go down more than that
great but i i thought he tells me and
and i could tell after he fought that
other guy at ellis mania i saw him
had serious like i don't know a month
later
he was like twice the size and i
remember i remember busted his balls in
the elevator going
wow just had the fight and just
scratched the whole like let's get in
the gym
thing because he got big but i also
think like watching that fight with him
and ryan
um and talking to him a little bit at
ellis mania before it um
i do think he's the type of guy he'll be
in shape dude he's just into it
yeah he's just [ __ ] committed that's
why i said yes because he's
him in bisping he's like he's doing
he's doing like videos of his journey
to beating my ass he's going to put in
the work yeah that's cool and you know
like you just said with izzy he's he's a
better striker than paul acosta but he
could get
caught and knocked out i feel like it's
the same thing but even more
questionable on my behalf because
i'm a better striker than him but i'm
still jason ellis
the better striker does he have any does
he have any background in anything
he's puerto rican so he's definitely
fought he just thinks he likes the
script there's definitely a history
there's got to be
doesn't count his boxing looked like he
wasn't he's better that uh he has better
hands than cm punk
yep i'm not trying to be funny that's
nice i'll back that yeah that's not
something
it's saying a little bit remember you
were trying to fight cm punk
i would still fight that guy what i mean
i remember when he's in the ufc we're
trying to yes dude
i was talking to dana about he was like
dude you know many people ask me for
that and i was like
boy do i feel like an idiot i'm sure
everybody i'd love your professional
opinion
how can a guy train with duke rufus for
years and still throw punches like like
my wife that's how hard the game is
i understand that's how hard it is but i
i i'm not expecting him to go out there
and be [ __ ] anderson in his peak
prime
but i'm saying how did some people do
shadow boxing for the [ __ ] camera
how do you work with youtube ability but
then also i think
when he was in the training room he
unmets and stuff and maybe sparring he
looked okay
but you're going from zero experience to
the main card in the ufc
yeah so he's like holy [ __ ] this isn't
the wwe it's like
nah [ __ ] and his name's mickey gall
he's gonna twist your [ __ ] head off
when you you know when you hit pads when
you hit pads does your coach every now
and then correct you on your [ __ ]
because you haven't been there for a
couple days yeah
okay imagine if you've been training for
six months or a year whatever he's been
training for
and now mickey goal's coming at you full
speed do you think that right hand is
going to be the one that your coach has
been working no no no no forgot
everything
like i said i don't i never expected him
to be out like even crisp in the fight
i'm saying like when he'd do those like
uh the the like warm-up pieces
the ufc would do that they'd show him
like like shadow boxing and i'm like
even though that was bad
he throws he throws like like a lego
boss but you know brock lesnar who's a
perfect example freak
never be good at striking he'll never be
good freak of all freaks
and even his striking like jesus christ
dude and he's working with the best in
the world
and athletically you're talking maybe
the biggest freak ever in the ufc
it just takes a long time that's that
hughes comp punch
well there's there's there's he tried
body composition makeups too that that
you can't get around like jake shields
perfect
jake shields is a gnarly [ __ ] mma
fighter
and a insane grappler he'll just never
you could work on it as much as you want
he's super disciplined okay some
people's body doesn't have the
the fast twitch that guy yeah jake
shields then the guy the other guy that
hangs out with the diaz brothers don't
[ __ ] come at me
did you guys you won't even see me
anyway but [ __ ] calm down smoke weed
let's calm down
his buddy that fought in bellator this
weekend that [ __ ] threw an illegal
headbutt did you see that's what
daniel's time is
the blind guy coach dude
this guy jake shield what is with the
people that train with
two of the best boxers in mma have the
worst boxing in mma like if you're the
diaz brothers buddy
and you're like yeah [ __ ] vegan meals
bellator i'm like what the [ __ ] why
can't you
punch at all they didn't they were just
like no dude you teach me wrestling and
they're like what about my hands i don't
know you figure that [ __ ] out yourself
it was the worst jiu jitsu guy aj is
the worst of [ __ ] sportsmanship i've
ever seen in my life
dude is losing halfway through the fight
he's got the mount and [ __ ] headbutts
the guy
beyond the league what'd they do [ __ ]
nothing
kept the fight going they're arguing
with each other beltram was trying to
tell him to shut up at what you didn't
see the end
no so the end they're still bitching at
each other because the dude's like haha
you lost and dears his boys
an angry little [ __ ] man he's a very
you can tell he's a mean
world-class jiu-jitsu yeah world-class
oh great stop okay
just cause you're world class doesn't
mean you have to be a dick no i agree we
just discussed that
but i think that's a personality thing
too look at this headbot right
because he's like that in grappling like
just a headbutt in the man
and the ref does nothing he tried to he
he did i think he
gave him a warning or he stood him up at
one point and told him to calm down
yeah that has to be my you got to take
points away dude you can't have it i
didn't
maybe they did but at the very end he
tried beltran tried to get him to
shake hands and little angry guy walked
off and
beltran went out of the cage and grabbed
him pulled him by the hand
back and was like you guys shake shake
[ __ ] hands
and then they look he wouldn't do it
because that aj kid lost
yeah and he was super pissed and bitter
about it and the other guy was kind of a
little bit happy about it which
made aj even angrier and then at the
very end when aj was like
i'm not even talking then you could hear
the mic and he was like it's a lot
different this ain't social media of
your [ __ ] man baby and i was like wow
you just you just caught him
and beat him but seriously that dude
shouldn't even be in bellator for doing
that i highly doubt they have him back
oh really you want uh i mean i don't i
don't know how many fights he has in
there
they're bad you can't have that dude i
agree it's gonna happen
even if he was good you shouldn't no you
can't have it dude can't have that [ __ ]
yes i thought
why can't the dears brothers go look
dude
i appreciate all the wrestling he got
three and two
i think he got thrown into the mix
pretty hard which i do give him credit
for at least he fought
people that were good jiu jitsu
background it's not like they're gonna
toss some you know [ __ ]
i i always say i'm telling you i think
it's a a lot of it's genetic like some
people are just not cut out for like
like a lot of grapplers you see there's
some that have it and some that don't
like
docker a is a perfect example elite
level grappler he somehow was able to
make that transition he could snap off
some points he put in the work dude
because at one point he didn't have that
and then he put it like anise and silver
and all that but you could tell he put
in
actual work and he wasn't he's rude
yeah he's no he's hardcore like i can
think of like maybe three or four people
americans above like uh there's the
super buff
insane buff [ __ ] house dude the baby no
the white kid um
there's tone in there's uh the no super
john
talk [ __ ] to everyone oh uh gordon
gordon ryan who's
first team he's [ __ ] insane and then
and then uh
andre galvao i mean he's he's up there
if he's so good on the ground how come
he's in the mount
and he can't finish that other guy that
you don't know i didn't see it i didn't
see it i don't know
but i'm just saying he gets people down
he does is it just like because you can
throw strikes that really nullifies
somebody yeah he's a great
trying to figure out the mma game and
he's not taking as much risk because he
don't want to get reversed or something
i don't know
he's not even in the fight he's not
doing the den and dillas whatever that
moment
who [ __ ] ding dong dingbat jesus
christ that guy's got serious brain
damage
to them it's a little bit sad though
what
he's stud on the ground very good
clinically
like the dumbest most in the clouds
[ __ ] i've ever heard talk
how so ever i could beat brock lesnar
[ __ ] i could beat mike tyson i could be
branded spreading sharp on the ground
any what million dollars right now yeah
i know that dude's doing interviews
where he's saying that about
just pick a name i know but he's ju it's
all just
ryan garcia i know million dollars
boxing or mma i know look if you've seen
the guy
he hits like a girl and i'm like dude
you're you're
insane but it's all just uh a persona
for him
for us to talk about him do you believe
that yes yes did you see the interview
with ariel hewani the other day
i i know dylan and he's faking it it's
all fake
ah dude you know who is training one of
his main training partners
he had me tweet at the guy sometimes
shut the [ __ ] up stud you know you know
what do you mean why keep doing that
just because he [ __ ] grapples
people good uh dude i'm monster count
box
doesn't need to barks about it a lot too
yeah i know but you know who is
one of his old fake he goes look at my
pads i'm insane and then he walks up and
goes ha ha ha i'm gonna
oh because you're talking about him
that's brilliant because because his
jiu-jitsu is so he's so stupid right now
yeah and i'm on video [ __ ] because
dylan's going like this
got him see i already said i was stupid
you're tuning in
so i covered my tracks but you know you
who his main training partner one of his
main training partners is
conor mcgregor exactly so yeah that
doesn't happen
he watched that and and saw how much
value it has
in in being that guy and getting
attention getting it get ben askren dude
wait ben askren's full of [ __ ] he just
talks [ __ ] because he knows he's a
grappler and you're gonna tune in to
watch him lose
what what
he knew he was going to lose and was
just saying that no he talks all that
[ __ ] he could back it up
[ __ ] can't back it up you go to the
ground i refuse to learn his name
[ __ ] you have you ever seen but ben
asking if you're talking about striking
some of the worst striking we've ever
seen in the ufc
yeah yeah yeah but he can wrestle his
[ __ ] tail off
yeah he's got really bad strength he's
striking so bad he looks like he never
even it's like i don't care
says that defensive ben askren uh in
comparison to someone like dylan danis
ben askren's actually funny ben asprin
is very funny he's saying
i find both he's done some [ __ ] both of
them are funny because i don't take
either one seriously
that's true yeah they're both it's like
yeah
you like are you mad at [ __ ] hogan
when he gives a hot take
to me it's no different than wwe like
like when they do up when they cut a
promo they say
wrestling oh kogan ain't giving a hot
take well the bad reference but it's
like uh i don't know jericho jericho
i don't know
who gives a [ __ ] whoa because
wrestling's [ __ ]
fake yeah but and [ __ ] but you're
gonna get hammered
i did all your [ __ ] moves in half an
hour i was very sorry any [ __ ] wheel
kicks can i
see my wheel kick and then see my
[ __ ] suplex see which sport is real
yeah he's good at duplexing yeah yeah
because it's not
[ __ ] real [ __ ] off no but
these guys they're just they're doing
these takes and people are paying
attention there's value to it
yeah there isn't because it's
entertaining freaking me out man 100
percent
fake like he has he ever said do you go
dude see the last thing i just said
[ __ ] people are freaking out
uh colby covington what do you think of
him
um yeah i've heard that that's fake but
i don't believe it i think that he's
really an [ __ ]
nope one of the best people i know also
also very funny
oh [ __ ] off because he went to your food
truck of course he's on his best
behavior no
he's on the [ __ ] spotlight he was it
oh [ __ ] no he would never
love you but then on camera no no he was
on with dude let's just
quit the gimmick we don't need the girls
here he's like dude you know i can't do
that
like i gotta run with you it's like
that's that that that's all planned
that's all shtick
he's a good dude it's all dude it's
entertainment
it's entertainment fighting now i've
heard guys talking i've heard
[ __ ] dick four or five people off the
air that know have said the same thing
you're suckers you're sucking you you're
the dumb ones i'm
cool a lot of people
sucker right now but trust me when we
get off the camera i'm gonna [ __ ] be
totally telling
you don't be into [ __ ] i'm telling you
off he is a [ __ ] [ __ ] not into
a racist horse he's a [ __ ] idiot
wait wait
i'm gonna be super friendly when the
[ __ ] camera's off trust me yeah
do you tell people alice is actually
pleasant off the camera like i am you've
always been nice
it's not true i'm a mig
i'm a d i've stuck so much [ __ ] on you
you don't even know yeah i don't care
damn it because i know you don't mean it
yeah i didn't really
i'm trying to think of my head yeah but
for him it's all uh it's all a
shtick dude it's like come on
100 like does he do you think he's had
sexual relations with any of those girls
i doubt it's sexual relationships i
doubt it's sexually i don't
[ __ ] be working with me
i've been watching the dudes a little
bit [ __ ] with no he had internet no
because he came on my show and he
there were two hired girls you'll love
this they're two hundred girls
and i go dude you gotta quit this
because i'm not gonna go along with it
he goes
i don't care do your thing man then
we'll figure out so like
so we get done with the interview you
know he's doing the whole stick and i go
there i go dude we gotta go in the back
and eat that's where we do the interview
he was okay cool and the girls are back
then it's just awkward and he's like
and he's like dude what what can i do
because i'm telling you it's all
enacteos
uh hey he looks at one of the girls we
hired you know
gorgeous girls this brazilian goes hey
uh babe will you
he goes but while they're filming we
come massage my shoulders like while i'm
eating she goes
[ __ ] you
and he goes all right that's cool oh
yeah
no he's just he's just thinking about
like how can i make piss so many people
off who are going to tune in but you're
saying
right after the camera's off he doesn't
talk to them
no not at all he's not sexually
interested in them is he married
i don't know is he gay no he likes
chicks but
as far that was a business it's a
business he was like
someone's going to pay see you in the
interview was he mean to you
no no no so then how is it different
when he's on or off camera
in the interview he's saying he's mean
to his opponents and the girls are just
okay off camera is he like actually i
really like my opponent
i don't think he hates any of them i
don't
this is heartbreaking to me i don't know
i
like mma he probably hates me saying
this
he's gonna deny it oh all the guys i'm
gonna believe him yep
he's better actor than you i believe his
hatred for the world and his opponents
[ __ ] but he's good though so he's good
and that's why i don't
he's less annoying because he's a real
guy that can back it up can't argue he's
a dylan dennis is not
d but yeah yeah dylan dance only has
what five pro
mma fights against [ __ ] i could beat
up every dude he fought
bomb fights and you didn't even stand
with him at all
shot in from like six foot away to grab
an ankle cancelled when
i mean you know what douglas lima he's
like douglas lemur's gonna give me a
fire
is that fake he's saying is that a fake
thing
when he says that no i i think it's fake
yeah douglas
is not going to fight him because he
would be murdered
douglas but it makes no sense for
douglas lima
doesn't was like wait what no fighting
championships yeah doesn't even know who
dylan i mean he does
dylan downs as far as the mma world is
very famous because you know there's a
lot
yeah yeah i know i'm kind of [ __ ]
great i know
and he is he's legit i mean like in in
the world of grap
uh grappling he's he's okay
i like him five percent more
i'll take it enjoy my job you guys did a
great job you did a great job thank you
my job's done
i will i would no longer tweet shut the
[ __ ] up
my gay friend uh told me there's a bunch
of fake me's on grindr
i need you to investigate yeah there's
like a bunch of fake pictures of you
it's not there's like profiles that are
that's kind of flattering right i'm
totally okay with it
fake me on there man i haven't got it
there
but how's grinder work is it only like
in a mile radius
you know if you have like i have like
the platinum account or something so
like it goes like spreads that way
further so how but
from around i don't know how these apps
work so how does it work so is it
worldwide like some dude in japan's like
yeah i'll fly out there
yeah oh wow yeah sometimes i see
hey man how's it going and i'll see it's
like 7 thousand miles and i'm like what
nope
oh i fly to you he [ __ ] my butt but if
[ __ ] my buddy
but if it was like 40 miles away you'd
be down
i mean if you want to drive over and
suck it sure i don't do that anymore
i don't everyone's too nasty so i don't
know what do you mean too nasty
people are i'm married to a girl so i
don't want to bring home chlamydia
like i have more than once so now i just
from [ __ ] dude it's great for your
podcast but
you can get chlamydia from dude you can
get gonorrhea from a [ __ ]
they have it in their mouths you got it
i got all of them
from a [ __ ] because i don't i don't
know because they've got it in their
mouth weird yes you know this i
i've heard these urban myths i didn't
know it was a real thing
see look there's just all people that's
grinder yeah and grinders are only for
dudes
oh yeah oh you know there's there's a
couple girls in there every now and then
it's like hey i want to try
when are you straight is there any
straight gay boys that want to like do a
girl and i'm like hey
but no not like i said not any i can't
there was a time there when katie and i
were
free-spirited and learning the ropes of
sleeping with all different kinds of
people and getting bit by
diseases or people that say they can do
something they're a little bit sketchy
and it's like oh man i need this guy out
of this house i need this girl out of
the house
i [ __ ] up so now we just don't play
any of that anymore it's just more
i have a couple people that don't know
and trust and that's it
a nice battery but it's grinding uh for
the size it's uh tinder 10 different
girls and then you're on tinder too
yep tender is not as easy because
in my tender eyes because there's girls
involved well that and i state in my
account that i'm a married man that
you're just getting sex you're not
getting a relationship and most girls
are not interested in that and they're
on tinder
dude almost every tender girl says uh
you know no [ __ ] boys or you know if
you're looking to just [ __ ] swipe
everybody states the whole they only
want to have a relationship that's
that's 90 percent
tinder i don't i'm just not
saying those girls it's like you're
intended i mean come on right i mean
yeah but on grindr the dudes are like
sucking literally
just here no i get photos of [ __ ]
not even hello that's aggressive yeah
but that's dude since i did that article
that and
like came out what are properly this app
magazine like the gay
big thing in the gay community so they
did like a big interview on me and stuff
that changed everything that how so
the gay community knows me i'm in a part
of the community so there's like all
these people that have reached out going
i think it's really brave and there's
not many people like you that talk about
it and so i have like a
big audience that don't know the show
they don't know skateboarding
they just know this one article and they
think it's right yeah i love it i love
i'm not a part of when you buy you're
kind of not a part of any of them
but to be no one claims you you're
saying buys the buy
a lot of gay people who say buy is just
a straight boy who's like
either in denial or just a straight boy
oh interesting it's like you're gonna be
fully gay you just don't know it yet i'm
like what
i'm 48. [ __ ] my wife everybody
happened are you sure it's gonna happen
yeah
so they i think that's like an old
school
memory of old school theory did you did
you first come out on the jason ella
show
no i came out on the stern show on stern
yeah how long ago
four four years ago when he came back to
the show the next day
what'd howard say um that's why they
want me they
want me on there to torture my penis or
to tell everybody i'm gay that's it like
you're just a
you're a pawn sorry but you are it's
like i got i got home did they know you
were gonna do it like they're like hey
jason what are you gonna talk about he's
like i'm gonna come out
yeah they did the what they always do
the interview beforehand and i knew from
coming out to my my wife's girlfriends
like she told them
and they were like i think it's really
cool and i started talking to them about
it
and it was they were you know sort of
thought it was even cool because a lot
of them a lot of my friends are
gay girls so they're like oh cool and
they
made it feel good and then that was
right when the stern show were like hey
we're going to have you back on
is there anything new in your life you
want to talk about
and i remember i could feel it man i
could feel talking about it to these
girls
made me feel better about myself because
i could see in their eyes they weren't
like
that's cool man that you're doing that
like they were like yeah
and i was like they generally are not
disgusted like i would think most people
would be
yeah which is a [ __ ] cringe thing
dude like it
so when the interview came i was like
i'll just just say it jason so i just
told them and i remember the guy
interviewing me going oh what was that
oh uh are you sure you want to talk
about that i'm like yeah this one bring
it up oh
okay and he's just like oh are you like
we're gonna get
[ __ ] gay on the radio yeah yeah yeah
jesus big macho guys
was howard like so how's the love life
like how did
he tee it up i can't exactly remember
but i knew the question was coming
from the tone before he said it so and i
was like oh he comes here
the gay thing you were you were sweating
bullets
it has been nerve-wracking i'm more to
me it's more about doing really good on
the stern show when i'm going there to
me it's like a fight or a skateboard
contest like all my gotta kill it
everything is
is on fire and it has no it all costs so
i only remember the one thing that i
knew i wasn't going to allow was
the time before i was on there he talked
a lot about my dad
molesting me and uh and i was like i get
it because some of you are like laughing
at it and [ __ ] but if you say like my
dad i suck my dad's dick again
i'm probably going to check you and tell
you to stop doing that i don't really
feel like it's that funny anymore it's
not cool
but he didn't you know he's not like
that yeah just that was the only thing
that i had
that i would draw the line at like if
you started going oh you're gonna suck
at your dad's dick i'm like you know
what dude
not that funny yeah now now that i've
thought about it a lot not really that
funny at all you should think about it a
little bit too
but so then so when then you came out
where they're like oh that's cool man
it's a weird that place is very
understanding and that was cool and we
were
being funny at all cost being funny dude
like i put
nipple clamps on my balls and had george
to take them off
not because i want nipple clamps on my
ball like entertainment they
i remember stern going dude can he take
him off and i was like yeah yeah and i
could tell sir was like you're [ __ ]
knocking out of the park right now
and i was like stern and i are doing
radio gold i'm doing radio gold with
howard stern
i can see gary everybody going this guy
is [ __ ] killing it right now
i'm like that's what i came to do was to
knock it out of the park
they were like saying we're the best
[ __ ] show ever afterwards and i'm
like yes jason yes
that's sk and so the next time i came
you can't really beat it you know it was
more like about
gay things and i really just don't like
started to turn into
sad stuff like why oh molestation i'm
like i'm actually doing really good
i'm having a great time and sucking
dicks i don't cry when i do it
it's fun i'm having fun with my life my
wife knows nobody's
cheating my kids know like it's all out
and then after you did howard stern then
when he came back to your show
did you i'm sure like because you're i
don't know
you know i guess the fan base they
probably had no idea right so it's a bit
of a shock did ratings drop down or was
it like yeah a little bit i mean i only
know because you don't tell me ratings
but i know from social media social
media dropped a lot
still has been affected from that i get
it people some people are angry some
people just like it's not for me anymore
who gives up the my thing is to anybody
who gives a [ __ ] dude
i don't get it i don't understand well
because you're a little bit
different when you're a little bit more
open-minded and kind of a
kind-hearted person when it boils down
to it some people
have a stick up their ass and certain
things
trigger it and they can't get past it
the worst ones to me are people that
know me
and knew me beforehand and now are like
a little off because of it yeah i'm like
ain't trying to [ __ ] you dude
like that's so [ __ ] up you know like
i'm also bi like ain't trying to [ __ ]
your wife either yeah
but now that i'm out like you're
thinking i might be checking your ass
it's insulting to me
like the [ __ ] um cerrone
uh somebody showed me on my show like
cerrone called me a [ __ ] to joe rogan on
the joe rogan podcast and i was like
it was up on the wall and i was like
that's not cool guys were
and i knew they would come on the show
and stuff yeah i don't you know cerrone
i don't think he meant it that way
i know i did i actually got in trouble
because that article posted they
said what's the worst thing that you
think that's happened since you've come
out and i would say probably that
like that and knowing there were some
other friends that said to one other
friend
hey is this true about alice being bi
and they're like yeah and they're like
[ __ ] and knowing that some of my friends
have said that behind my back it it
hurts it breaks breaks my heart a little
bit i've had my heart broken a bunch of
times it's okay i'm a big boy yeah but
i'm not gonna lie
it did break my heart same as watching
that video but as donna was on the show
he was explaining to joe that he was on
my show
with uh the lioness and i was trying to
bond with the lioness about being gay
and
i'm bi donald's like wait what the [ __ ]
and i'm like it's a funny story he was
trying to tell him funny it wasn't ready
and he didn't just he didn't see it
coming and he reacted the way that
he would around his boys and i get that
because people forget
i'm not gay i'm bi and i'm really kind
of manly for
a straight guy like i do yeah a lot of
stupid dude [ __ ]
and and i think so for cerrone
especially in the in the joe rogan like
in in the in the studio there he for i
don't think he was mean to hurt you
you know and you know i took it that way
i oh of course you would telling you i
could
easily yeah boys inside both things
that comment when then joe said so what
did you really think he was like i
thought what the [ __ ] this guy's
[ __ ] and i'm like why would you call
me a [ __ ]
but i get that word is not the same to
you to to me
it doesn't carry the same weight and i
thought joe why don't you say something
you're the wiser man you ain't saying
something so i feel like you agree with
him that i'm a [ __ ]
that's me i know dude i'm just telling
you what my brain thought when i saw the
video
that's your view and then i validated it
and then when i did the interview and
talked about
that they posted it and tagged both of
them and i
said back hey like you don't you weren't
there
it really didn't i understand like
you're about to say what their angle was
and i didn't think that it was actually
that malicious
i felt like it was just them being dudes
and then
the uh the magazine they they're like
that's what you said and i was like i
know that's what i said
you need to stand up for yourself and
i'm like i am but i don't need doctor
just wants
some people like man do you hear this
dude said this about him like wait and
i'll look i'm like
that's nothing but any reference to joe
rogan they're gonna want to use that i
mean that's obviously good publicity i
did not retweet that
i told jason i was like i could totally
get how that would be
really heartbreaking not only because
it's a popular person but sad for me
but donald j like jason you know
idolized donald in a way because of
his lifestyle the way he fought and
everything like that was a big idol of
his
but i told jason i was like this is
really important and i'm glad it worked
out this way because
donald cerrone is representative of i
think a lot of guys
especially in this country that aren't
homophobic
that aren't they don't hate you or
dislike you or want to know
what what is is that he looked at you
associated you with his type of guy you
like moto
you like mma you're [ __ ] tough you
got cowgirl and all of a sudden
his brain broke when he found out that
he's like oh you're one of them
and i think it's really important to for
everyone to realize like
gay or straight or bi it doesn't have to
match up with
like the kind of the tropes that we all
know like i think it's really super
important for
jason to come out and be as courageous
as he has because there's a million
[ __ ] alpha male moto moto riding
horse breaking uh mma fighting dudes who
are
in the closet that they're only in in
public mainstream media their only view
of gay is lance bass and
yes andy cohen and stuff like that no
obviously that's you know do your thing
but for jason to come out and do it it
gives them
the ability to break through that weird
barrier that we all had and donald
donald like a lot of macho dudes like a
lot of alpha males has that barrier
where he's like
wait wait you're you know i think it's
weird but anyone who's super aggressive
about him like
well what's your deal there's something
that's a personal one what's going on
why are you so upset that he said bye
what's wrong with you yeah
i gotta if they could they i don't know
jason's into
you know [ __ ] eagles i i wouldn't
even battle that'd be bad i would not i
don't
whatever i don't get i mean eagles don't
really can they really
one two three well let's say he's raped
not that guy yeah i hear you but you
know what i'm saying like i think it was
like hell yeah
and i'm like that's what i'm saying he
was like no he actually knows sign
language he said hell yeah
if i could have sign language
conversations with an eagle i definitely
would not be here right now what if you
were
gonna be [ __ ] the eagle
and then i did this this is how you guys
do it right now
satisfy you i [ __ ] eagle but but i
stop you keep going
i'm saying it's out of all animals
that's a nice majestic animal to [ __ ] it
doesn't have a dick do you know that
perfect eagle stone yeah bird stump
eagles don't i just know that because i
sang a song sir eagle [ __ ] when i had a
band
and people were like hey man i did
somebody someone was like just so you
know sir eagle [ __ ] couldn't even [ __ ]
anybody
eagles don't have [ __ ] and i was like
[ __ ] get on the google it's like son
of a [ __ ] i'm gonna stop singing a song
no the jason show has taught me a lot of
stuff about animals dicks
turtle shit's a stick out snake has two
dicks shark has two dicks
oh if you say the wrong thing i get
check fact all the time we get emails
non-stop i mean you gotta know your [ __ ]
man
well mma no one's fat checking that
right not mma just eagle dick stuff
eagle dick stuff or i'll say stop
talking corona politics
you'll get a million articles hey man
yeah i stay out way to go
your award's in the mail way to go dude
yeah i gotta run away from that one yeah
i don't have anything to say anymore i'm
like yeah you're probably right
yeah what can you do [ __ ] me so you're
doing the ella show five days a week
yeah
and then i started my own podcast the
jason podcast because fans are like we
do a show anymore i'm like i don't
really need to i didn't
i don't want to i did one for mayhem
because mayhem was trying to get his
[ __ ] together
and then it seemed like what how's he
doing he's not doing good
and that's why him and i no longer talk
because i said
i will work with you if you stay i'm
willing to try and help you get out of
this
if you're willing to do the work i would
also help him out if he's willing to do
the work right well i don't want to
i sense that he is not and i
told him from the start of me accepting
him back into my life
i have a 15 year old daughter you know
if you're not [ __ ] straight
yeah no you're disrespecting her and
every other girl on the planet because
you shouldn't even be here right now
this is your
second chance that you barely deserve so
[ __ ] earn it
and i didn't feel like he was doing that
so i wasn't gonna waste my
time and energy doing a show and so i
just said five shows a week and then
doing a podcast
i'm only doing that podcast because i
have something to say for now and if i
don't have something to say then i'm not
doing it you don't do it i'm not i don't
there's no money i'm not doing it for
money i'm doing it because i'm having
like fans
on the show interviewing the fans so
they get to hear
themselves and talk in their community
and then i'm just talking about
things at the start of the show that
what i've used to be successful
so it's not like book smarts like you
were saying it's like
what are some of the things in my
mindset that i've used in my life to get
where i've
where i've gone to where i am now these
are
um uneducated
power moves on how to be successful like
a mindset of someone that
maybe wasn't given all the the tools to
be that successful
yeah but [ __ ] you can't beat it
that's basically what the problem it's
experience though that's what you're
giving them
yeah right and just to no i'm not
reading it i know like if you never give
up all the things that have happened
everywhere you'd be like you should just
stop
it looks like it's not going to work out
if you keep going
it works out if you really want it that
is yeah you know it's a really
important kind of point you know and i i
don't have it figured out i certainly
don't
but what i have noticed is that when it
comes to things
like just the human aspect of living to
divorce yourself from your left brain
the intellectual side of it
what you've learned uh in an x-snow
standpoint
the the actual interaction of being
human of dealing with insecurities of
dealing with fear
dealing with pain um that only gets
developed
through experience and someone else's
ability to
to kind of communicate that experience
to you um
trying to get sober trying to deal with
a divorce trying to deal with uh an
abusive
uh loved one there's no book you can
read
you know there's no there's no course
you can take to do that that has to be
you have to turn it inward and and then
learn from other people
who have turned it inward and then they
can share it with you it's like that
dude i remember jason when you were
going through it i remember you're in
the thick of it at the time i did
i did your show at sirius and it was off
well sure you're in the thick of it
i remember i was like dude where's your
where's your porsche at
i mean you had the gt3 was it g3 porsche
turbo 911
that's right it's a white one right yeah
all black yeah i was like dude where
where the [ __ ] your car at
like i got rid of it you had to get rid
of it dude
but you didn't give a [ __ ] i was like
that's kind of cool because to me at the
time i was like what
it's gone like yeah dude i have to get
rid of it it doesn't matter
well that's because it's happened so
many times in my life yeah
it's just like uh things are there and
then they get taken away or you have to
do something to make it i mean i got
divorced dude at one point i had nothing
i had skateboarder pro skateboarder had
an agent and a business manager and they
didn't pay my taxes for five years so at
the end of my skateboard career
i found out that i hadn't paid taxes for
seven years so i sold my house
here sold my house to pay the taxes then
the penalties
so now i'm paying penalties as i slowly
retire from being skateboarded which
means
my check's shrinking as i'm paying
penalties so i can tell that my
skateboard crew is coming to an end
and i'm gonna have nothing to show for
it yeah and there's no more
in me to get more money from
skateboarding i'm [ __ ] busted up i'm
not gonna
win any contest doesn't matter how much
i practice so then the radio show
tony hawk show i start talking as soon
as i start talking i'm like
i'm way better at this than [ __ ]
skateboarding and everyone in series is
like who is this guy
we need to give him a job would you like
to move to la to get a job yeah all
right
listen to the stern show and like i said
with you with this
with the football to the mma when i got
this shot
and i knew that i had a talent on here
way more than i did in skateboarding i'm
like
you were top three in the world in
skateboarding and you know that you were
not naturally gifted at this correct
maybe
one of the least gifted out of all the
people i know in my
[ __ ] 20 years of skateboarding and
you made it to top three you probably
could have won if you actually [ __ ]
stopped drinking for a couple days and
then i was like this is your second
you're gonna [ __ ] rip it and then i
was the same thing all day
sir what's stern doing what's open here
bubba loves these [ __ ] got nothing on
me man i [ __ ]
it's so tempting to tell everybody that
every day because i was like
500 million dollars [ __ ] listen to
this you [ __ ] gerbil you're nothing
to me
and you know obviously kept that on but
that was the fire
and then the show got gigantic with that
but when it got big people like
everyone's listening i was like yeah i
know
how did you know i didn't i was just
like this is [ __ ] going manifest
like this the whole way and i can't see
or hear
any other way and then it worked but
divorce came so i made money moved to
beverly hills got divorced
down to a one-bedroom apartment in santa
monica gave my ex-wife all the money
and then work up work up oh guess what
because you're paying her money you
didn't pay taxes pink penalty again
i'm like we're back again so penalty
ex-wife
broke business manager telling me like
hey i noticed you spent some money at
starbucks today and i'm like
yeah coffee for the show dude things got
i when i went on dates where i had 70
bucks in my pocket and didn't tell her
that that was what i had in my pocket
because my business manager was like you
don't have any more money so i was
depressed and you got kids yeah or at
least they you want they got every
that's why i didn't
it wasn't that bad i gave her all the
money they were okay
they got they got everything nothing
changed to them they saw me in my
apartment i stayed happy
for them but then build up again and
then
you know here we are still i'm back
you're back
i could do i hadn't bought a car yet i
gave my mercedes back but because of all
this pandemic i'm like why do i don't
buy one yeah want a car so now i just
i've rented a
a 68 what's your saber oh sick i'm just
driving around
giant convertible to saber right now
like you park it outside
it's on the street down the street oh he
looks like he looks like
a hit man from [ __ ] goodfellas hell
yeah but that's my new thing i've just
ran a car like once a month and
cruise on the weekends who rents porsche
old school
lamborghini whatever that's it someone
with their [ __ ] together
that's how it's like like that honestly
that's how jason and i got to know kids
were pumped it's like a giant boat in
the back they were like fighting
oh your daughter looks very pumped
because she's too cool to be honest
they're so
comfortable you guys don't know about
that no it's hysterical you're 15 you
take a photo you have to put your hand
my wife and i fell on the floor laughing
when we saw that video because it's like
every time i pull my phone out my
daughter goes
my face is not going to be on your piece
of [ __ ] old man social media
you uncool you guys better yeah that's
how you guys met where
well we met because i was listening to
the show i was always a fan
and uh they were talking [ __ ] on dr drew
and i and i dare you and i caught
uh it wasn't actually it wasn't jason
mostly was other his friends i was gonna
say
[ __ ] it was mostly his former
co-host it was [ __ ] broad dog yeah it
was and uh i
i was driving in my car i'll never i was
just pulling up to my old house in
venice
oh seven years ago yeah and uh
i i was like [ __ ] it i dialed and i was
like hey uh
i'm uh i'm dr drew's radio co-host i
work with him every day i
think i could shed some light on this
situation and
he's only in it for television like to
be famous and i was like that's so
[ __ ] up dude that you can say that
without even knowing oh you stuck up all
the
way
oh yeah different right but but they
were there was you know like i don't
even know i've already been friends with
drew
i love you so of course i was like a
person the guy calls me and asked me if
i'm okay
he just that's not on tv he's great yeah
and uh so i called the show and then we
had a conversation on the air
and jason at first was not believing it
was me like he's like you do ra you're
a psycho mike and i was like yeah yeah
no i and he didn't know
of me or anything but he's like you do
radio in la and i was like yeah withdrew
and
so finally we got past that and then i
started i was like he's actually yes
awesome and so at the very end of the
show uh
jason goes why don't you add me on your
radio show
okay uh i'll hang give him let me get
your contact after i hang up
yes she got contact and i emailed him
came on love line i hate that guy after
that
jason goes why don't you come on my
radio show i was like okay
come on do stuff for me i'll do stuff
for you it's all right here go away
quickly
and that's the [ __ ] i hate that's how
we started meeting until we met and then
the second time i came on jason's show
um i go i'm gonna i got a little
surprise for you i got a little surprise
for you
and i know i know we haven't
explicitly talked about it but i
guarantee in his brain he's like oh
wacky radio guy he's going to come in in
a
bear costume or something and i came
with drew with dr drew and then that and
then
it just kind of opened up from there and
then yeah hang around dr drew and not
love him that's how we got to know know
each other though because
that that era that he's talking about
when things were getting really dark
yeah i'll never forget he did a
interview i believe it was tyra banks
and yeah no no no he had tyra on his
show
and and uh after uh it sounded fine to
me but after the interview jason went on
the air for like 20 minutes was talking
about how disappointed and angry he was
at how
shitty it went and he he's angry at
himself and blah blah blah
she was in a good interview or what um i
mean i don't really remember it but i
don't think i got
it's usually i get him to kind of like
me and spark up and i just couldn't get
him to do it she wasn't interested in me
she thought i was lame
and uh ruined it for it didn't take much
back then for me to have a bad day so
who gives a [ __ ] i
do i [ __ ] i did there was times there
where i've had people come in with like
sunglasses and go who am i talking to
yeah great
and then i've made them go sunglasses
off and go
[ __ ] man yeah who is this guy i'm like
[ __ ] dude you got a skill right here
so when it doesn't work out and the
person keeps the shades on i'm like
maybe i don't have any ability and i
suck
yeah he was getting really like
self-deprecating and i could hear it
and i had like been at that place before
and i was had to recently had a divorce
myself
much less intention i didn't have kids
at the time so but i i was like hearing
him
and i and i was sympathizing like deeply
well this guy barely knew yeah he could
relate and so i got home and i emailed
him
and i was like hey dude i know i don't
know you that well but like i'm in the
business like you and i
you can't you just gotta dust yourself
off and get back up again because you do
a great show and everything
and he emailed me back and i think was
surprised
that i would reach out like that i've
always since i've been friends with mike
the sincerity and what a really
kind-hearted person he is oh my
god has has shined from the start so
i've always especially when i was going
through a lot of stuff
i would text him and ask if i could talk
to him
because i didn't have that many friends
in my life especially anybody that had
gone through
anything like that yeah and i didn't
have a therapist at the time
so i was just like well i don't know
what i'm doing man i'm thinking about
like not doing anything anymore and just
leaving everything and he would
talk me off the [ __ ] cliff more than
once i would call because i knew rather
him
when things got real bad because i don't
want to have this conversation
sorry about having this conversation i
don't want to have this conversation
with him about how i'm feeling like i
don't want to be around anymore yeah
it's [ __ ] embarrassing i know but
it's got to the point where i'm
gonna if i'm calling him or drew it's
bad it's bad it's bad
it's real bad because i'm like i'm like
i probably called three times and hung
up before it went through and i was like
[ __ ] it i'm just gonna do i don't even
know what's happening anymore i should
probably [ __ ] die and they're like
dude
calm down and i'm like okay thank you
this person that i
i trust him like i trust him he's not
out for it i'm so honest there's no
agenda dude
you get it like at one point i'm up here
and everyone else is nobody
because they're [ __ ] it's like human
nature to snake
[ __ ] off the bigger guy it's just your
nature it's like
girls with big asses walk by you go
you can't you're like don't look at her
ass don't look at her ass i'm like what
is worse
following it or tell like you have to
argue with yourself i feel like human
nature
is like oh you're doing really good whoa
this whoa you got that car whoa
you know what we should we should we
should [ __ ] do something together
i think you're really funny i think your
shoes are great i think everything you
do is great
we should we should hang out and i'm
like okay
so now i've got like five or six people
around me
that don't like me they're like they
know that so well no they like the idea
like you're right
the conversation off there yeah they
like the idea of you right
is it it just and that when you're when
you're
when you can be this high and be that
low all in the same person
and you figure out that these people if
you died tomorrow they
be on the next guy it's [ __ ]
heartbreaking heartbreaking
you thought because i won't [ __ ] die
for you like if
you know i mean i've got certain friends
where if you talk [ __ ] on their chick
and i'm at a restaurant
i i'd be like hey man you know like
uh that's my [ __ ] friend's chick 100
you want to get [ __ ] snapped out yeah
any of any of you you i don't even need
to [ __ ] why the hell would i defend you
look at this but i would defend you i'm
just saying it comes to that like my
my wife i'm [ __ ] my wife i'll [ __ ]
you up
[ __ ] my kids i'll [ __ ] you up [ __ ]
my friends because i will [ __ ] ride
or die for him yeah so you need to
expect the same that's it that's all it
is when you don't get it it's
heartbreaking i would have died for you
and you're like yeah you're not doing
that well anymore i'm gonna go over here
i told you that what i told you that
last week when you were telling me that
story about the
the biker bar yeah it's what i told you
about jason i was like i
let's let's not kid ourselves jason's
crazy but there's very few people in the
world that aren't my daughter or my wife
where i was like i don't
doubt for one second that jason's
motives and intentions are always pure
he'll always have my back i
can always trust jason yep um there's
there's there's very few people in the
world i can say that
there's there's very few there's zero
doubt in my mind like at any situation
i couldn't count on jason if i go
through my rolodex i'm like
you got six it's nature you're in the
game of
the highest level and if you're not 100
dedicated to it you're second best and
you might not even exist on this
platform
so if you're not going 100 if you're
going 100 how do i know if your feelings
are being taken care of
how do i know if i stood on your toes
when i'm too busy trying to [ __ ]
win yeah it's only when you get there
because that's why i excuse it sometimes
that's
that's the other thing some people have
heard my feelings where i'm like you
didn't even know
i excuse it i agree it's not yeah it's
not it's it's you're on fire right now
and you're trying to go somewhere oh
i've been there yep i've been there
where someone was like hey jason i was
like [ __ ]
i only see this one goal i don't even
see
you yep and now i'm like what oh [ __ ]
dude i'm so
sorry like yeah there's so many people
in my life
where if i get a time alone with them i
would i've if they really if i really
care about him i've probably apologized
to them because but but you know it it's
nature
so that's why i don't get hurt by it as
much anymore because
you're in a i just assume you're in a
time in your life where you need 100
focus on this one thing that you're
trying to achieve when you get it
hopefully you'll start paying it back to
everybody else because that's what i'm
doing so i just assume that's what
happened don't
don't mishear me here because i
unashamedly i'm super pro-american i
love this country i love everything
about it love america
i love captain it seems like you know
again
the [ __ ] on america no i started with
the [ __ ] eagles guys
i love everything about this country and
i'm i'm proud when i go overseas i'm
proud to see
america maybe you should stay there do
you think do you think
do you think that because of what we're
talking about where it's like the nature
of the beast
a system like a capitalist country like
this where we
not only is it a capitalist country but
we since you're a kid
you've independence and the sake of
being self-reliant
um in in growing and being successful in
this country do you think that that's
one of the main problems like and where
we're getting away from like who we
should be as humans like living a more
tribal life where we
like taking where we're not trying to
make as much money as possible and
making doggy dogs
we're just living in a tribe of 100
people and we all know
why we're all successful you know yes no
it's a tough one but
i mean i think like on a personal level
like maybe we are we have gotten away
from like what the
the animal of homo sapiens really kind
of should be doing to
well it's a rat race you're copying
everybody yeah and if everybody's
splitting off and getting all the money
and keeping it for themselves then
you're like whoa i need to get all the
money and keep it for myself the family
now it's a race to the top everybody's
racing and nobody wants to
help carry anybody but i think the
quarantine's helped with that
like because with me i'm like
you know i have a seventh month old and
since the quarantine hit like i've been
[ __ ] dad changing his diaper i'm with
him 24 7 waking up with him put him to
bed
put my kid to bed waking up with my kid
so i'm like mr
dad when before the quarantine dude
trying to be a good stand-up comic i'm
traveling four weekends a month
right i'm doing the podcast four days a
week i'm just i'm there at night putting
in bed waking up with them but then i'm
off to work i think the quarantine now
with the quarantine it's like
you're yeah this is important that's
what's important dude so i called my
agent like dude i don't
if it comes back i'm not doing four
weekends in a row
one weekend a month that's it i'll do my
sits around town i'm not doing that
anymore dude
i do think away from my family that's
not important or a good point it's a
good point but i do think
it's been very the the lockdown's been
fantastic
for people in that regard who are either
super
super broke and super wealthy so someone
like you who who has the the economics
you have an option you i know you don't
have an option
the economy has come back when you start
getting back to work i'm not saying i'm
just saying
it gave me perspective i'm like dude you
got to chill the [ __ ] out whereas
you're missing that's cool [ __ ] people
people
this is this moment those are the
moments that uh
because we're all you know biggest show
ever
[ __ ] i mean [ __ ] everybody watch that
you did the [ __ ] funniest thing you
did the greatest punch or the greatest
those little buzzers that you get on
your well i'm like that's what life's
about winning
look at how much money i made just now
look i [ __ ] knew i do that
all those things there was so much work
to get them
versus you know my kid wrestling and
laughing with me and i have this little
thing and i'm like
okay that all i had to do was just stand
here for that oh my my son boston though
like i was playing with him that day and
we're wrestling he did something where
he was standing across cup
and he'd like stand on the table and you
know seven months and crawled across i'm
like this is [ __ ] dope
my girl's like yeah man tiger the same
[ __ ] and you missed it all i'm like
oh she's heartbreaking she goes when he
when he crawled for the first time
you're in australia on tour i'm like oh
oh my
you over here maybe his laugh mate yeah
but you were at the time i had to i'm
building a foundation at the time i had
a [ __ ] job gotta do what you gotta do
that
space where you can focus on the kids
i'm like i'm not i'm not telling you no
more i get it
i'm not telling either of you guys to
not be that guy because i think a lot of
your success has on both of you have
has been in your ambition and the and
the discipline to work hard and continue
grinding
but i will say like dr drew for a small
time
after he got out of residency worked in
a mental institution and he worked on a
wing that was with
early onset dementia okay and all of
these people all of his patients
all of them were um super
super high functioning highly successful
people they were
um and it led him to believe like a lot
of it was sleep deprivation that
led to this early onset dementia so it
would be generals
um uh uh super like district attorneys
surgeons
these people who live an nfl a former
nfl coach i heard he wouldn't name names
but
so these people who are just living high
strung super
super achievers when they were getting
the news
that uh the end has come
not one of them ever ever ever
ever bitched and moaned about how much
money they make how much money they
didn't make what car they drove
their achievements it was all like i
should have spent more time with my
family
every single one of them i should have
spent more time with it i i regret
my relationships you know
look there's that and then there's work
ethic you show your kids a work ethic
because if you don't have a work ethic
in this life i think of [ __ ] how many
gifts you've got you're going to turn
into a useful slob
agree right you see your dad or your
mother hustling and you remember them
as people that were hustlers and that is
installed in you
yeah that's like i didn't see him all
the time because he was
you can't you can't go through life with
no job no you can't they just [ __ ] on
you around here for that
and and also and i i'm not i don't want
to make a chauvinistic statement but i
do think it is different for guys
at fathers there is such we we value
each other for our achievements so much
more i think than than women do like
i i mean i really look at guys and how
they function and how they function in
the world as like
wow like that's the guy i want to i
rarely go like
he's such a good dad yeah i mean i
should but i rarely do that
to be fully honest i always go man that
guy [ __ ] grinds that guy
he does it and um it's hard to strike
that balance my father
um he's not a very open vulnerable guy
but we had this conversation probably
about 10 15 years ago
we were at the dodger game and uh
i said you know i dad i never i never
really appreciated
f enough how hard you work because my
father
would travel like 200 some days a year
he was all kind of he worked at this big
multi-purpose business firm and uh
as a consultant and he would he has huge
clients all over korea spent a lot of
time korea a lot of time in
chicago nashville india all over the
place and uh
he traveled like crazy and he would fly
[ __ ] home from
korea or or or spain
for 12 15 hours and then immediately
come to like show up for like the last
three innings of like my little league
games and stuff
and and when you're seven you're like
well my dad's here great
but i never i was like i never really
appreciated how
how hard you worked to make a great life
and then also how much you
you killed yourself to even try to be be
there
for for me and he very unlike my father
because he's not like this
open guy he said yeah but you know i i
live with a lot of guilt because i miss
so much your life and i i don't want to
be that guy i have to weigh
the consequence and dividend of it he's
like yes i was successful and i gave you
a great life i gave you opportunities
but
i i missed out probably you know we
didn't have
my father and i didn't really have a
relationship till i was like 30. that's
no
well you made a good kid because you're
a good dad well thank you you're a good
husband too
uh you talked to my wife about that i
feel like if i was going to [ __ ] on
anybody i would [ __ ] on her
i mean i don't mean
that's your [ __ ] joke you can have it
i i just feel like you do a lot and
i'm wow this is she's gonna kick my ass
no let's hear it
i just feel like he's always fixing
himself
for them to get to be in this and it
seems like there's nothing wrong um
um there's a lot of truth to that in a
sense
seems like only one of them's working
which what i'm scared of
oh well that's that's very true that i
mean you have much better reason to be
scared of my wife i don't think i've
ever met your wife
she's [ __ ] awesome and one time
alright i gotta come in here with her we
should you should um
my was great no she's amazing but
there's a lot of truth to that in that
i'm definitely he probably has a lot
more work to do though
yeah yeah i reckon he is more trying to
fight oh yeah
he's trying to bail you out but but how
much work for how many years
before you get a pet on the back because
because like i was doing a great work my
wife does
when no one's around she's she's very
supportive
and she's she always
she'll randomly you know tell me she's
like i really appreciate how much harder
you were you're you're you're a great
job
at that yeah but but i want education in
my life
like my wife the stuff that i don't want
and then you don't give it but you want
it well the stuff that i don't provide
show me show me and then i will show you
back
yeah this is what i'm talking about mike
you are sexy as [ __ ] let me suck your
dick right now
and i'm like whoa really right now and
you're like babe babe jason's here i'm
like wow i don't mind that's what i'm
talking about
because you're a sexy [ __ ]
brad pitt yeah he is that's what we call
him a cinnamon bread
you're like lou ferrigno's really hot
[Laughter]
daughter
i try hard as a mother and i try her as
a father and i do a lot of stuff and my
wife is supportive of that
but the stuff that i i'm lacking in i
still i do need a lot of work i mean i
do need to do this stuff like being
willing to just give affection that's
not sexual
i'm not good i'm not good i'm not good
at it compared to other husbands i mean
i
i don't randomly just go up and give my
wife a big hug i can't help but my
chick's ass is so insane like i give her
a hug
of course i'm gonna start grabbing her
ass and then i'm gone yeah
can't help it i'm like oh thanks for
dinner yeah
oh and does she like it though my girl
[ __ ] yeah does she like it though well
yeah but
like like her parents have been like
grabbing her ass she's like jesus christ
dude yeah i wouldn't do that in front of
her dad i'd probably let that one go
good for you though thank you especially
especially hispanics
family you wake up with a [ __ ] it's
impossible dude
it's impossible yeah i don't do that i
don't remember kids either like i feel
like i'll be grabbing some ass and i
hear them coming i'm like
oh yeah now come in the kitchen hey dad
i'm like hey yep
yep they're not doing it but yeah i try
to
because she's very sexy and we're are
you guys married yeah
we're super into sex too so i'm assuming
i'm still attractive to her
so i think that we i mean it triggers
the bone pretty quick
so so i i do try to make a mental note
of doing one
where i don't go there but i'm confused
i'm like i
love you and i think you're sexy yeah i
know and it's like you know what
sometimes
i know you think i'm sexy you don't need
to tell me that by grabbing my ass or
the other parts you know i'm just like a
i'm just a
it's my wife you know we're together and
i'm like he grabbed my dick
she signed up for it you know right so
every now and then i'm like hey a little
bit of a president but but is she
because the relationship you're in is
she uh
buy two or she oh yeah both by yeah
yeah so that's parties and she has great
taste that's better
which is so she's super picky so but
when it happens thank god sometimes like
she's like girls only like fat chicks
that would be tough i'm a chubby chaser
but if she did like
one time it happened with two bigger
girls and a limo
back when we're on fire i'll tell this
story please tell me larry flint
well we got we did an event where the
band was 30's yeah
no no here make me be sick four
sometimes wait you got
fours fours keep the [ __ ]
thirties you are savage
i didn't even know they made four it's
like [ __ ] half a shoe like a toenail
and calling it a sneaker
the four i mean sometimes but two this
guy katherine four
no every time he gives me one i feel
sick
dude those are so strong i just figured
this is ending soon i can pass that in
the parking lot
yeah yeah okay so anyway we'll do this
and current events when you're out
great so ben plays um at the strip club
and big event everybody's awesome
drinking all right good night and i got
a big
hammer limo to be a douche this has to
be what 2004
or this is um hummer limo
on seven oh no i got it when it was past
cool this is recent
oh yeah like uh oh this is the radio
show
[ __ ] was that the day you got in the
fight with simon woodsock
where you drove out to long beach no no
okay no this is before that okay couple
years before that hummer limo so
five years ago okay that's fair so um
yeah i had a wig on and i was dressed
like a metal guy or whatever i had like
uh wolf pant leggings on and no t-shirt
sweet battle jacket [ __ ] full [ __ ]
so i got the limo
and um you know all these girls are like
let me come home with you
i'm like ah i don't know i'm gonna ask
katie
and then it comes down to these two
bigger girls that are fans and usually
fans are off limits that's the deal with
katie
really no no no jersey chasers gets
jersey
chases cool
what do you call them what what are
groupies called in the skate world
pekka ants uh what a they're called real
corkers mate ramp
dundee what the [ __ ] are you talking
about rampores no
hoes i don't know virtos rojos pro hoes
that's what they're called pro hoes
okay so so some no bro hoes i don't like
to call them pro
hosts because these are my fans which
are kind of my friends it turns out in
the end these two people
hold up became my friends yeah sure but
at the time you [ __ ] [ __ ] hey but
when you hey
just so you know he hated you not true i
really like uh when you say
chubby i need oh oh 300
350. oh chubby and fats a little
we're a little off yeah big big [ __ ] i
just don't like saying fat it's mean
is it yeah they might like it or
what's the correct term obese overweight
i would like to go there about thick
yeah i just call them big
big girls big girls that's a big girl
thick is like demi lovato
that's not 350. thick sexy thick is sexy
that giant that's offensive is it oh
she's a giant
she's a giant woman so you're a
giant guy that's [ __ ] dude that's a
guy so offensive
guy if you're like dude check out this
chair she's a giant
i'm very confused like dylan dennis all
over again i don't know what's happening
dude ass your chicks if you call them
giants let me know how it goes for you
okay what about what about precious big
girls i like big so anyway these big
girls are
uh at the limo shows up and they're like
let me go home with you and i'm like ah
there's two of them yeah
and the keys of the piano one black one
what 600 pounds
a lot of guys can handle the 600 pound
loving yeah we'll see that was back when
katie and i were like a batman and robin
sex machine like if
whoever we got a hold of she would take
the area where i wasn't
or it would just turn into this thing
where as soon as i'd start banging
maybe her face would be on my back
challenge each other like who's gonna do
like if i could sneak around the back
here and yeah
wow i knew in her head she'd be like oh
is he really i'm like that's right i am
i'm there first so so like a treasure so
we leave
and then i tell her these big girls are
like super into me and she's like really
i'm like oh come in come on it's an
event and she's like all right
and does she like big girls or giants as
you call them no
big girls speak that's right and uh so
she goes we'll
go back and pick him up i'm like okay so
i go hey
we're going to come back and get pulled
up in the hummer like let's go hold up
in the hammer and got him in there
and then so it's on in the back of the
hammer oh in the bummer oh yeah [ __ ]
yeah
[ __ ] yeah getting all the things off
everywhere things are
flying out like whoa just giant things
everywhere
and then at one point flags nobody
submitted in the [ __ ] limo
so it's a it's a bone zone everyone's
underneath everybody and then
it goes it's still gone then i get back
to the house on the couch
they needed a snack and i'm one of them
on the couch and the couch from the
pumping
starts to separate oh oh because the
sectional couch
yeah and her bigness is like moving
things apart
yeah and i'm you know i mean she's on
top of me and i'm on the big one and
there's another one underneath the side
like
near the back of me but i'm just trying
to figure it out like
logistically because they're so big i'm
like pumping here
and then where's the other big one this
is the gap where's the giant here
the giants to the right yeah no under me
they're
under here oh you stacked you
you double stuffed them oreo style yeah
and then this bit
leaves it leaves and she just goes
and i go with her because i'm in her so
we both go boom
boom and she goes she's a fan
she goes oh red dragons
and my wife is out out
she hated that she can't turn off yeah
he fanned out he said like the cheesiest
thing anyone could ever see she's out
oh i am not licking that anymore yeah
she was out
yeah so that was the end of that one
what was the end of that for but no but
no more
no so no more fans are off limit for you
we're also brought to you by on
itonit.com the best supplements
on planet earth what do you need man
protein
krill oil mct earth grown nutrients we
got you covered
mct oil the best you've ever had they're
almonds my favorite my face is on the
cover
whatever whey protein plant-based
protein protein bars protein bites
home listen coffee the [ __ ] yeah black
rifle and onyx collab yeah
caffeine caffeine crystals say what
onyx.com fighter 10 10
off the entire damn site you need uh
fitness what do you need you own
at home fitness on at six on demand
streaming fitness we got kettlebells
club macy's steel maces sandbags battle
ropes we got it all
go to onit.com fighter on it dot com
slash fighter for 10 off
pretty easy yeah no everything so
everything else is and what about
do you have any no's for her no any
holocauster
i would let her [ __ ] holocaust so i get
it he's hot whatever harvey weinstein
that's where he draws the line she's
just really it's more like i'm like come
on do it do it and she's like hey
i'm good relax [ __ ] one time i've got
a
guy that's really cool i like him he's a
good dude
and they were hanging out [ __ ] for a
while and i was like this is awesome
and she's like he played his album for
me [ __ ] oh
whatever and he just got cut for playing
his album after he [ __ ] his
gangster i'm like man the guy was joking
he's trying to [ __ ] branch out and
dude
do you mind if i just run this body real
quick she's all [ __ ] see you
apparently she tried to he tried to play
like a bunch of it and talked about each
song oh
[ __ ] that guy listen you may because
it's a musician
it does it kind of makes you like hey
you want to hear my music but imagine
just
imagine for any moment if it was any
other line of work if like
a football player is [ __ ] a chicken
he's like you you want to watch some
game tape
put on the highlights brandon's like the
lane of daddy's like you want to see me
knock out crow cop dude real quick
i could totally blow you if you showed
me a video if you're knocking that card
off that's hey mind if i play the best
of the week on uh below the bell
like what the [ __ ] that's insane and if
if a giant lady showed me a video of her
kicking croak up in the face
that's different that's different the
other direction of course
uh gives current events because i know
these guys got to get out of here yours
first
prince pizza new york [ __ ] yeah coming
tomorrow it's enough to keep me here in
la
but have you ever had prince pizza i
don't even know
pizza in new york it looks very good my
favorite pizza in new york
now they're opening up in los angeles oh
that's why you peddle a black hole but
it's in west hollywood which is might as
well be in new york for me
[ __ ] west hollywood well right now
there's no traffic that's a good point
you could also postmates
what's wrong with west hollywood nothing
wrong it's just that's 40 minutes of my
day
i'm going there it's fantastic best
pizza you can get in new york i'm going
to come in here awesome what do you see
what other stuff you've got for me to
eat before i go home
yeah that looks good dude it's square
slices
that one pepperoni does look like a
prolapse though it's so nice to do that
thing he sends you pro look at the one
in the front nope he sent it once on
dude we can't be friends we keep doing
this he stopped
good for you yeah i let him know my
boundaries well you're the only person
you and josh wolfe
joshua sent me this thing this elbow in
a guy's ass i'm like
hey bud don't send me this i was in the
kids might see sounds like my grinder
account i was like thanks josh
oh it's grinding accounts they show that
that's next that's the next
the next three crusade is fist that's
what people do when they
fisting yeah it's a big thing people do
it a lot
i feel like it's dangerous i don't know
i mean there's certain things where i'm
i
you know i don't want to hate on it i'm
like i'm like okay i'm not going to make
fun of you for it
again don't give a [ __ ] seems pretty
challenging to me that's what you want
to do
looks painful but you enjoy it that's
what i said power that's what i said
you need lube let me know they need a
lot they use grease
yeah one guy had his whole family full
of crisco and then the josh wolfe one
yep that's what they do pizza though you
say
yeah uh prince street pizza what else
you got chin yeah
okay so we've talked about this in the
past kevin durant
uh was infamous for being on his fake
instagram account and
you guys don't follow sports really i
know who kevin durant is so kevin durant
notoriously known for being on social
media create
burner accounts it was like talking [ __ ]
to like a 15 year old kid like you ain't
[ __ ]
you're never gonna be [ __ ] in your life
and it came out the kid's like holy [ __ ]
this is kevin durant
he'd go at trolls and they found out he
had burner accounts they found out
because he forgot to log out of his
official account and
responded thinking that he was on his
fake account he's learned his lesson and
now he's just talking [ __ ] on his
official account
learnt his lesson he keeps [ __ ] up he
has not
learned anything i've heard a lot of
people personally with my prediction for
their well-being i take it back lakers
in one
hilarious it's kind of like uh
what's that band hey now you're an
all-star what's that smash mouth
if you talk you know if you talk [ __ ] on
smash mouth they talk [ __ ] back yep
currently and i don't know about
currently but on the show for a while
tally figured out that if you talk [ __ ]
on smash mouth they go
uh you know so many so many records sold
so stick that up your ass
so we were like oh yeah we need to talk
[ __ ] and the lead singer of trapped
too he'll spend the entire day talking
[ __ ] back to you if you if you leave
if you can't be doing well in life if
you're wasting time couldn't agree more
i don't think dave grohl spends any time
yelling at chris i don't think
metallica's gonna
argue their stance like it's not maybe
lars it's not a good sign he might
this is the tweet that went viral why
you such a weirdo you're too wealthy for
this you really went and followed my
girl that's why
she blocked you weirdo wait he my bad
actually pressed following i liked all
her picks my phone tripping
look at this it's just saturday night he
just went off and started replying to
everybody
wait he if you tell [ __ ] he finds your
girlfriend and talk [ __ ] to her well she
seems pretty hot so i
i'm sure he was like just followed her
and then it's a critic's girl
he's like dude what the [ __ ] dude
they're not playing right now right no
he needs to play
well he plays for brooklyn he had
surgery on his knee
i think well i got a surgery i don't
tell anybody's girlfriend to go [ __ ]
themselves
no what's he doing dude yeah he needs to
get out you got 300 million dollars in
the bank
or or go buy a car or just do something
or embrace a black porsche
or embrace this like like dana white
dana white's got a half a billion
dollars
he'll still to this day talk [ __ ] with a
guy to with four followers he'll sit
there for [ __ ]
you're a piece of [ __ ] maybe you're just
that guy
and write it right you guys know skip
bayless
yeah yeah yeah he made up his own
account shout out he's on the show he's
like man you're doing really good dude i
can't get enough of first date
and then it was his account everyone's
like uh you posted he went
ah [ __ ] he wrote himself off to me so
hard with that i barely knew who he was
and then when i heard that
as a person that has a show really
no way jason keep up the great work [ __ ]
off
[ __ ] off hey job you're killing it i
don't mind you mispronounced names all
the time
i love you dude i'd make a fake can't be
like [ __ ] yeah unless you're big homo
what do you guys suck at trucking dicks
like i'm not pumping myself up i'm
bashing myself like come on
separately i just you're already a
hassle
you signed a 200 million dollar deal who
gives a [ __ ]
dylan dennis needs to get another cat
you can totally beat brock lesnar you're
the best
[ __ ] idiot so a lot of them do i bet
what else you got
so last week you broke off a piece of
your bike and this popped up the other
day
simon cowell accidentally broke his back
while riding his electric
bike broke his back i seen him i'm doing
what i'm doing on my show today i'm
bashing this mountain bike
no electric bike just like but there's
like like i have an electric
mountain bike no dude hybrid electric
bike
at his house riding around with his kids
yep he's learned a valuable lesson that
he's gonna roll up what does he say
[ __ ] who sells it
advice if you buy an electric trail bike
read the manual before you write it for
the first time
i've broken part of my bike freaking
dude you you go
deep and he goes um read the mat come on
like did you put it together with the
wheel on your neck like what
if it's if it started rolling the reason
that you crashed is because you can't
ride a bicycle
and you're very breaking dude i love
your story of not getting the gig with
simon county oh i know
[ __ ] [ __ ] my bed but he went to his
house
he went to his house he almost got the
gig i was gonna give be the host of the
x factor
and i i met with him simon cowell and
simon fuller at simon
simon's house yeah and uh they were
having this great time it was really
very was very nice to me looked like
chain smoking like a bond villain house
insane house insane bugattis and [ __ ]
iron man's house
and uh finally he's like you know
basically i'm looking for a host who's
rough around the edges who's willing to
take risks you know not someone who's so
straightforward and i go
no you're not he goes and i was thinking
everybody's going to be like
kind of and i was like what do you mean
i was like well
it's live television you don't really
want someone who's
unpredictable and spontaneous and rough
around the edges
and he's like oh i'm glad you got it
figured out more than i do and i was
like uh
no i mean oh if you do i'm your guy but
you know and then see ya you knew you
shut yourself down with that comment
i i knew i knew because of the reaction
it wasn't
it wasn't like oh what do you mean it
was like everyone's silent like no one
talks back to him and i was like oh [ __ ]
well
he broke his back mike yes he did so i
know even steve
e-bike street bike which is impossible
to do no some people are goobers and
some people aren't
like i see the electric scooters all
over they're all over venice
and every one out of every 10 people
they get them they put their credit card
in and they get it and they get on there
and they are different ebike you
literally have to pedal to get the thing
going
dude and then there's different levels
it's like riding a bicycle what are you
doing
what are you doing he broke his back
right he's gonna bicycle it he's in his
backyard
jesus christ he's not travis pastrana
either he wasn't like going to give him
backfire no but
there's a guy who's a good friend of
travis pastrana's this guy is a
major [ __ ] and i am allowed to say that
a full
[ __ ] whole pass to be like you flimsy
piece of [ __ ] you're like a [ __ ]
talking butterfly
trust persona crazy killing it tony hawk
what's tony hawk just what just skating
skating on money like like scrooge
mcduck it like screams
i mean i mean michael jordan's got a lot
of divorces under his belt so you got to
look
that'll hurt you he's three and three in
the
one height of his career yep well one he
said michael jordan of skateboarding
easily
everybody knows tony hawk easily best
thing i heard the other day have you
ever heard a bad thing about tony hawk
uh yeah and it wasn't true well i'm
saying like maybe around your crew but
like
any time i like in public if you're like
tony hawk was like i love that dude
because he's a great person
yeah i don't know my catholic invented
the 900 same thing
he's a really good guy genuinely good
guy i went to the ramp the other day
with him
skating making jokes about how i'm like
man i feel like after about an hour
my legs can't hold he's like that's what
i do every day now we've got about an
hour and then that's it
like really [ __ ] demos two demos a
day
does he doing what business what's he
doing business like is he
what's it like well they're bringing
back the video game right he's
completely solid oh no i'm just saying
does like every day does he
does he do a show or anything i knew he
used to have sean's
[ __ ] right yeah he did the the show
on on my channel for a while and then i
remember that they weren't making it
that easy for him anymore and and
he's gonna come out he's like you know
i'm talking about driving to la to do a
show because he won't let me do it down
here
he's like i'm out dude yeah so he just
skates his
video game helps i think it's coming
back that's what i think skateboarders
what a gem
oh like all little kids that are up and
coming what a [ __ ] joke like what
that's the other thing i noticed at the
ramp there's like little people there
there's the new generation
and he's friends with like these little
girls like 14 they brought a dad came
and brought some other kids so he's like
oh my god i'm at the tony ramp it's a
private session
tony comes over on the deck like i'm
just showing my wife i'm like watch this
dude
he comes over he's like kind of wheels
you got there man
looking good out there like wow he
starts giving good encouragement
notices he's working on a trick gives
him some pointers on the deck
[ __ ] don't [ __ ] people don't realize
yeah what a beast where like this guy is
what a good dude this kid's like
that's like michael jordan be like dude
when you shoot you need to put your
elbow he does it all
you're going to listen to everybody
anybody that wants it sounds like arnold
day
wow and he goes to all skateparks
everywhere he's with these kids all day
does the younger generation know who he
is maybe from the video game yeah
no because he's he's the dog
he's the godfather birdhouse all the
people under him his son's pro
he sounds good as [ __ ] riley is [ __ ]
gnarly
wow how old is he 25. he's a dj too
right like
i've been on tour with riley hawk and
then all of a sudden i hang out with
riley hawk he's got a [ __ ] aussie
osbourne tattoo
i'm like what the [ __ ] are you long-ass
hair what's up ellis oh my god what got
a beard and [ __ ]
27 yeah it has to be a lot of pressure
when your dad's [ __ ]
it's not it's not it's like he doesn't
he's never been this guy it's like you
gotta [ __ ] make it
he's just he just makes him do his thing
he's never been aggressive
tony lives in la san diego [ __ ] right
he does yeah la jolla
carl's badminton give his address just
kidding
what else you got so former wwe
superstar marty jannetty went on
facebook
and uh he basically confessed to
murdering someone at 13.
and he also confessed that it wasn't his
first
murder cts there was another issue a
couple years ago where
he wrote that he wanted to sleep with
the daughter that he raised because
she's not his biological daughter
and a lot of people are just saying he's
a very sick man it's cte
he tried to sue the wwe to take care of
his medical bills
at some point but that didn't happen
this was the very first time i made a
man disappear they never found him they
should have looked in the
chat chattahoochee river but winnie the
girl in these pics
i liked you so damn much spelling that
great whatever
probably my favorite but i promised
myself way back then nobody would ever
hurt me again that includes you i love
you but you hurt me with your [ __ ]
jamaican jealousy you can go your own
way i don't need you
the girl's probably like what the [ __ ]
oh
no how much of your head gets hit when
you're wrestling
you might just be a bad guy yeah yeah or
or
because also he was able to write this
like cts just like you forget stuff
and whatever you wrote this all out it
could be remembered old school [ __ ]
mental illness unrelated to cte too
benoit they're like oh steroids no bad
guy yeah
just a terrible [ __ ] human being that
and crazy exists
yeah is he really old
i don't know yes he i don't know exactly
how old he is
he's up there definitely passing maybe
he's just trying to so i wa
before he dies maybe oh he's 60. he's
only 60 dude yeah but he's a wrestler
yeah and he said that's 140 in russia i
was gonna say it's like any day
it's like a dog yeah yeah man jesus
christ man
[ __ ] him yeah [ __ ] that bad just a bad
guy you know it's not ct that's my guy
and there is a video of a australian
tourist
in a museum in italy he tried to take a
photo
with a statue but instead of standing
next to it he decided to sit on it
and he broke off its toe yeah [ __ ] this
video
he has to pay for it uh right now they
are trying to figure out whether they
are going to press
charges or not because initially they
wanted oh [ __ ] i have broken up
australian oh [ __ ] [ __ ] broke the
toes off
[ __ ] look at this [ __ ] right now but
i'll notice brush it off 200 years old
during like dude you always
10 million dollars they're trying to
restore it right now but he wrote a
letter to
the people who blew it on youtube
this [ __ ] doesn't need toes anyway you
ever seen that chick i think it's a
chick she's in some
fancy museum oh and it just goes domino
effect back up and get a selfie
and he hits it and he goes
it was like from 500 years ago asian art
and
all the statues going she's like this
dude do you know you know the guy who
owns the win casino steve wynn
is that he's blind yeah he's blind
billionaire
um this was 50 years ago but we worked
on the way we were at the win
doing he did it to my friend a radio
show inside the wind we didn't see this
happen but we were in the win when this
happened
he is a billionaire and bought another
priceless piece of art and he's blind
and [ __ ] put his hand through it like
completely ruined it because he's he's
blind and uh we were inside
when he touched the [ __ ] paintings it
was probably i i i i
don't know where is it i don't know yeah
i know i don't know it could be that
[ __ ]
it could be exaggerated that he broke
through but he he flawed the painting
because he was getting no it was there
oh don't worry dude no you hit the cheap
one we'll bring the other one in
stevie no you're not even touching it
dude
stevie wonder dress is so whack they
always say that they're like you look
great man
he can see because he's amazing no he
can [ __ ] see you can see the [ __ ]
he can see the whole time he can
[ __ ] see the whole time dude
there's video of your [ __ ] [ __ ] he
can see he [ __ ] admitted it
[ __ ] you he's like actually you have 22
no no he see
he said he could see a little bit which
means he could see way better before
when he was
all the people in the world he was
looking at your ass [ __ ]
he was looking at you that's why i get
the sunglasses you see that one [ __ ]
good eye
around looking for titties i can see all
the tears
he knows what's going on wow you didn't
know that
i know i didn't know he wondered a crazy
pervert everybody does
everybody crazy pervert they can see did
you ever hear about steve wynn what he
would do he had two
german shepherds and he would go up to
the office and have people like
pinned hide in the bathroom his german
shepherds would be like
that's kind of funny yeah he'd be like
you're seeing eye dogs
but they were so vicious people like oh
[ __ ] steve here and they
they'd hide and he's like his dogs would
attack staff
and pin him in corners and [ __ ] yeah
that's why he got in so much trouble
and he's like i'm blind i can't see what
the dogs were doing
[Laughter]
i want to hate on the guy but it's like
you can't see and you're
how the [ __ ] did you see how to get all
that money no i mean dude
trouble that's something like putin
would do like
trump oh yeah he hates trump he used to
be buddies but hates hate
was he born blind i don't know i don't
know
like did it just happen recently or is
he always him either
when he's 29 years diagnosed with yeah
there you go incredible
retin-a pigment pintos i think he'd be
allergic there'd be like some science to
get him some sidebar you have a billion
dollars dude you become cyborg is that
what you just said
yeah like put some [ __ ] in your brain
and let's go yeah there you go what else
you got how many
more you want one more that i know you
guys gotta do a show at two right he
does you gotta do [ __ ] too
i gotta give me one more uh just a fun
quick one then
not this one this is for next time that
one's creepy this is creepy this one a
frog gets a beetle and the beetle
escapes by going through its butt
after it's digested yes no i talked
about that on my show
and then i was like oh man does that
mean they're gonna figure out how
i can be eaten by a shark and [ __ ] out
and be alive no because i was like david
blaine needs to do that stunt
i need to see david blaine be eaten by a
shark and then go out there
yeah that'd be sick right then i would
believe it so he eats that little thing
you have a cute frog
so what this four hours or so it's four
hours
yeah so it's got to go through this
whole internet
and then look at it it's alive no
worries no worries he's like andy
dufresne and shawshank redemption yeah
that guy does not care he's like yeah
what did he the frame
oh he hit [ __ ] he's all through some
[ __ ] oh he crawled through some [ __ ] he
made it on the other side
i mean he had like a knife in his butt
or something didn't he hmm i don't think
so
he didn't put things in his brain nope
never did that was red my bad that's
right
wow shout out to that little bug if only
we could be that bug
i know you know dude it shows you
there's nothing better than
being digested alive and then coming out
of butt it would just be cool to be
eaten alive and go
nah not today it's not over son not
today you're gonna be very surprised if
only
the beetle knew jujitsu and he could
come out the ass and then jump on the
back
and submit the frog that would or if it
was like a scorpion or something and on
the way out of just
like speed thanks for stopping by
playing it
[ __ ] wow shout out to that little
beetle well dude we know you got another
show to get to
i missed you man thanks for having me i
love you dude yeah i know you're busy
but
i know you're busy do the tv screen
thing oh yeah
i got a new phone so i gotta give you
that yeah yep whatever we love you man
thank you for having me for the 50th
time i love it i'm always so uh
flattered we love both of you guys
thanks man oh chance yeah
thanks you too thanks that's it i'm in
salt lake city this thursday friday
saturday
the only tickets left are late thursday
and late saturday all right t5k.com
uh that's it man this fire kid we're out